so uh it's kind of a crazy story uh
there's a YouTuber named Hunter Avalon
we've had him on the show before I think
a couple years ago and I had no idea
that he lived or uh yeah I guess he
lived like like a couple doors down from
our building in Martinsburg West
Virginia where we have people currently
doing work and uh I'm I'm I'm just
finding I just started finding the story
out like an hour ago not even some guy
showed up he so he's dating someone that
guy's uh that woman's exboyfriend came
with a shotgun fired through the door
striking the woman trying to kill Hunter
avalone at least it appears according to
text messages that were released and uh
I don't know just it's just crazy little
shook up I had to you know call family
because it's just I don't know it's a
crazy story
there's a bunch of political stuff
obviously you've got uh uh this fake
story running V ramaswami wanting to run
as the libertarian candidate I don't
believe that's real the uh VES team has
refuted it saying this is outright lies
and it looks like just before the uh uh
uh the Iowa it's a caucus right Iowa
caucuses correct they're trying to uh
Spike the uh VI ramaswami uh campaign so
it is crazy uh you know a lot of crazy
things happen around the world but there
you know considering Hunter Avalon has
been a guest on the show he's a
political commentator you know I figur
we'll we'll we'll go over this one and
just yeah we we'll definitely talk about
this and we'll talk about a bunch of
other stuff we've got news about the uh
the Iowa caucus and Ronda santis uh Ron
and his team basically calling for
people outside the state to come in
caucus so that one's uh I don't know not
a good story we've got I think it's
Missouri I'll have to double check
because I'm just my brain is wrapped
around this holy crap some dude just
like the guy got into a out with
the cops took his own life I mean this
story's crazy and this happened down
like next like like effectively next
door to our building where we have
people and you know kind of wow I'm just
kind of screwed up over it but uh uh
Missouri I think it is wants to make
abortion murder so you know we'll
definitely talk about that but we do
have an awesome guest who uh rescued 255
people yeah is that it is 255 people and
that's not even the first time you've
done it so we're going to get into this
uh uh before we do ladies and gentlemen
man it is really hard to follow through
with the promo after reading all the
stuff and seeing what's going on
uh you know near us but head over to the
best song ever.com and you can pre-order
on iTunes and Amazon do you want to
switch to the other view because we
can't actually see the pre-order oh yeah
there you go so there you go the uh
pre-order on Amazon and iTunes together
again the best song ever it is the
greatest song ever written everyone
agrees and I can say that because I
didn't write it Jeremy baring of the
daily wire did and so this is the
culmination of some really big music
industry Fus a big middle finger we're
giving I probably shouldn't say that
considering we're trying to basically um
game the music industry as it is but uh
uh you know between us and the daily
wire we uh kind of want to stick it to
the big fat cats in the music industry
and and every industry basically that is
taken over by woke garbage and nonsense
and so what we did was we did a cover
version in a modern synth pop style of
Jeremy boring and Michael n's Smoky mic
in the god king song it is officially
launching on the 15th you can pre-order
on iTunes and Amazon right now and uh go
to the bestsong ever.com pre-order it
because what we're hoping to do is just
you know sell a bunch of these songs
have have it be have uh have an impact
and just let them know we are giving
them the middle finger so with uh with
your support if you're a fan of like
modern pop I guess you'll like it a lot
of people seem to like the song shout
out to Carter banks for producing it
also become a member over at
timcast.net work directly so we can we
can do things like give a big middle
finger but uh there is a the music video
is dropping on the 15th uh in the super
early hours of the morning and there we
Michael nolles and jery boring do make
an appearance as well as Phil leonti and
uh it's going to be a whole lot of fun
so that will be uh uh all throughout
next week we're going to be promoting it
and you can pre-order it now joining us
tonight to talk about this and all of
the people that he rescued and the
amazing work he's doing is rep Cory
Mills thanks for having me appreciate
welcome back yeah who are you what are
you doing uh so I represent uh the
congressional district for Florida 7 uh
which is pretty much just outside of
Orlando all of simal County and uh South
alucha area uh I live out in the the new
Sera Beach area so in the outer Island
but uh yeah it's good to be back it's
been a while right on man yeah and the
the big story is if we Google it and
it's like rep Cory Mills rescues 30
people and I'm like we need an updated
story on this cuz it's it's it's been a
few months I mean certainly that's not
the full number and and you actually
it's not the first time you've done this
even with with Afghanistan you helped
organize uh rescue flights to get in and
and bring people out well then we
actually conducted so in 2021 uh
obviously prior to me being elected we
actually conducted the very first
successful Overland Rescue of Americans
that ever been done it was a woman and
three children from Amaro Texas I mean
these are born and raised OT Texas
natives out of Ronnie Jackson's District
out of Texas 13 and you know when I saw
what was happening I mean just the
barbarism the the horrific incidents
that was occurring with Hamas the
terrorist organization that's an Irani
in backed organization that was just
slaughtering Israelis and uh others
there in in in the Gaza area I knew that
this Administration was going to do
absolutely nothing you know they had
they had no plan they had no strategy
they had no actual contingencies um and
so by October 10th I was already on a
plane and by October 11th I was
conducting the first rescue which was by
ground uh which was from tiberias and uh
hia Nazareth uh we pulled 32 out the
first day second day throughout the West
Bank uh Jerusalem south of Jerusalem
towards of Gaza area we pulled another
45 but uh in total we ended up getting
96 out through ground rescue 159 out
through air rescue and also shout out to
uh the Nazareth uh group and Glenn Beck
and all those guys who've been doing
amazing work who uh was supporting some
of the stuff that we were doing about
trying to get Charters out but uh yeah
we ended up getting about 255 people out
on the the second rescues and then uh
you know probably about three dozen or
so out in Afghanistan in 2021 so I don't
know if my routine is necessarily just
serving in Congress or trying to do Joe
Biden's job when he screws up everywhere
else yeah I guess but uh we'll get into
all that stuff so thanks for hanging out
it's going to be a blast we've got Han
Clair brimo of course hi I'm Han Clair
brimo I'm a writer for cnr.com that's
scanner news it's the best I'm working
on some coverage of the Martin Berg
story as we speak right now I'm excited
to get into this yes Ian cross and D
Corey it's great to see you man last I
can sense the humility just oozing out
of you now since you've joined
Congress I can feel it in you man like
what that must be last time you were
here you weren't in Congress you were
running I'm pretty sure you that was you
were campaigning while and now it's just
like you're like it's like I can it's
like you've like matured in a way but I
can only imagine what what the last year
has been like and I'll tell you I've
been really lucky like while I've been
in Congress I got put on some really
amazing committees I mean I'm on the
armed services committee I'm on the
Foreign Affairs committee um on the the
intelligence Special Operations
subcommittee military personnel
subcommittee oversight accountability
subcommittees I mean it's been a good
time like we actually are being
effective through the experience and
Merit that you know we kind of built
through everything unlike where you see
most of the time when you go in there
it's you know who's kissed the ring and
you know how much money did you donate
and so you know there's the Congress is
certainly a broken institution but I
think that the 11 18th Congress kind of
the America First Patriots has come in
we're trying to do our best to to repair
that and get back to constitutionality
yeah and Common Sense man like talk
about techn well we'll get into it on
the show because we got Serge on my
right over here what's happening yo yeah
I'm here kind of trying to react to the
news we got today just crazy to think
that happened in wburg anyways yeah
surge.com let's get to it so here's the
the first story this is a local news for
us out of Martinsburg West Virginia
officer involved shooting in Martinsburg
results in suspect taking his own life
this is YouTuber Hunter avalone he's
been a guest on this show he's a
political commentator he uh was with his
girlfriend her ex showed up attempting
to I I it would appear to kill Hunter
evalon and ended up shooting his ex and
then when police arrived on scene and uh
uh this is uh this was West Virginia
State Police this is I believe the
Martinsburg uh City as well as I think
I'm hearing rumors even Harper may have
responded maybe after the fact they uh
there's there's Hunter posted the video
you you you can't see anything you can
hear the uh uh the gunshots uh at I I I
don't know exactly what happened the guy
apparently had a shotgun and uh yeah so
let me I'll show you this tweet this is
from Hunter I I want to say this I mean
you know you got to be a bit in the
weeds to know uh Hunter avalone he's
he's a political commentator but you
know it's not I'm not trying to be a
dick or anything he's not the biggest
political commentator but he has been on
the show before and we we had no idea he
lived like two buildings down from us
from uh our Martinsburg building where
this is where we're building the coffee
shop it's where we're building the the
skate shop so this is this is local news
to us and uh he tweet he he tweeted this
I'm still trying to process this and I'm
most likely in shock as I write this but
only a few hours ago Holly's
ex-boyfriend Conrad shed up at my
apartment building with a shotgun he
shot through my building door injuring
Holly's leg in the process I recorded
the final moments in which we are hiding
on the back porch you can hear him shoot
at police before ultimately taking his
own life in my own effing apartment
hallway I'm still trying to process this
process this Holly and I are physically
okay but mentally this is going to do
some serious damage Holly's been amazing
and she's been incredibly brave and
strong throughout this ordeal he posted
uh this he said this was Conrad's final
text message with Holly after she'd been
injured she said please surrender I'm
losing a lot of blood the shooter
responds I never meant that no God damn
it leave him please said only if you
surrender and he said I will just live
your life for yourself and then he says
I should have killed the coward so when
firing through that door it appears the
the it this guy went to Hunter's house
to to kill him and uh there there
there's more to this I mean there's a
lot of reasons why I just you know what
man first and foremost I'll just say it
this way uh I I'm I I the reports from
the police are that they went to the
hospital it's it's superficial injuries
looks like Hunter's girlfriend's going
to be okay so I'm glad to hear that I uh
uh sent him a message you know but he
should take care of himself whatever
he's a couple uh buildings down from us
but this is this is this is crazy and
you know for us for me why I why I think
this is so important I mean it's
important you guys take security
seriously it's important you guys
understand uh the right to keep in bare
arms that's right uh Hunter should not
have been he should he should not have
been hiding on his back porch uh
I mean maybe he should have I don't know
he's in West Virginia I just got to say
man he should he should have a weapon I
don't know what else to say I don't know
I mean I think that we live in a time
that we have to understand that not only
is there a massive amount of mental
illness that's you know kind of going
around but we also have to acknowledge
that there's really been this kind of
devaluation on human life I mean you're
starting to see this callous approach to
where taking you know human lives mean
absolutely nothing and so I think that
we live in a day and age and
unfortunately that we should in uh I I
would encourage people to be able to
defend their own homes to understand
stand your ground and understand your
Castle Law to understand you know the
ability to try and protect your family
which is ultimately our inalienable
right under our Second Amendment right
so and and and this is why you know
every every argument made by every
anti-gun anti-2a person is going to be
like that man should not have had a gun
a good luck man that's such a ridiculous
argument crazy gu is going to find a
weapon you can 3D print them right so
I'm not I'm not here to C anything on
Hunter I'm not saying he did anything
wrong I'm just saying you know I hope I
hope in the future he looks to his his
personal defense for his home he's in a
constitutional carry state he can do it
and uh and he should and but but I am I
am glad the police were there and uh uh
were able to look I mean look I always
give the most uh Kudos ever to our First
Responders who are just amazing people I
mean these are the individuals that run
towards fire when everyone's running
around you know running away these are
the people that run towards gunfire when
other people are running away I mean The
Bravery of our men and women in in
uniform I I just don't think it can be
understated and how much we should
appreciate what they do dude you
mentioned the devaluing of human life
that's kind of been a trend and I I was
just talking to Dr Drew earlier on my
show and interviewed it was great talk
we talked about narcissism it came up
and like I was like what does that mean
that means I love myself cuz like in
like N means like when you're a kid and
it becomes like your your bonding
mechanisms become a threat so you go
Inward and you like kind of soothe
Yourself by ignoring others and then you
start to lose he explained it way better
he wrote a book on it but like I don't
know if it's the age if it's the if it's
the internet all the video games people
are diving into as because if it's being
kids set in front of a YouTube for three
hours when the mom's in the kitchen just
doing whatever if it's the drugs like
the Pharmaceuticals that kids are like
moms on amphetamines that are giving
birth to kids that have like hard time
their gut biomes that's all of it and I
think it's all of it I think it's a
culmination of like so many things not
to mention the fact that you have 22 23
year olds who've never knew America
without being at a time of War I mean
yeah what's that about Man the War
weariness what is that like a kid is
told like this is normal this is what we
are and it's like but that's horrible to
be I mean in my opinion conquest and
colonization of Iraq Afghan attempted
Afghanistan Syria Libya like it's
disgusting I don't it's just for oil as
far as I can tell or for resources but
like to be told like this is how it is
Hell welcome to the greatest country on
Earth we're conquesting all these other
countries but the problem is is like we
were talking about before the show
started I mean you've got this kind of
neoconservative neoliberal like liberal
kind kind of interventionist mindset
where they think that all of our you
know Warfare is still based in a kinetic
realm of gun to gun bomb to bomb bullet
to bullet and they completely ignore the
fact that the evolution of warfare is
now into the non-kinetic kind of
information Warfare propaganda Warfare
you know economic resource supply chain
and cyber I mean these are the areas
that we need to be focusing on and I'm
look I'm not an interventionist but I'm
not isolationist right we we need to be
protectionist and understand though that
there's certain things that have nothing
to do with us you know I would look at
Ukraine as one of the biggest models of
that and so for me you know the reasons
why we went into Iraq which lost you
know almost a million plus innocent
lives no no one you know I've spent
seven years of my life in Iraq I spent
almost three years of my life in
Afghanistan Kosovo Pakistan uh North
Somalia all these areas one of the
things that I've learned is that any
government at the end of War can try and
claim a victory but no one wins when it
comes to war you're always going to have
certain amounts of collateral damage
you're always going to have certain
people are going to lose their life who
shouldn't you're always going to make
sure that you're going to lose some of
someone's brothers and and and uncles
and fathers and husbands and things like
this in these wars and so we need to
stop treating lives as if we're pawns on
a chess board somewhere that we can just
basically move to play political
football we have to be smart in how we
not only protect our American people but
we protect our treasures and we protect
our ability to be able to be strong
again we have to get America First
agenda back on the Block and we have to
stop this interventionist mindset of the
1980s I watched I think it was Clint
Russell retweeted this is from a few
days ago some graphic of like veteran
suici how the deaths of uh active
military and it's like suicide is like
15 18% in 1980 and then it goes up and
over the years and now it's at like 45%
of active the does that work what
in the hell and that's just people that
are actually there in the military
getting I also contribute that to a
little bit of the wokeness that's
basically continued to try and utilize
this indoctrinating kind of uh process
where in our military you know there one
of one of the things that we strived so
hard for myself Matt Gat Jim Banks
Ronnie Jackson I mean so many of the
members of our armed services committee
and especially the milp subcommittee was
to get away from this idea that
meritocracy no longer can exist and it's
all about the diversity equity and
inclusion the Dei you know what we
really need to be focusing on for our
military which is what it used to be
focused on is things like increased
lethality Readiness and being properly
equipped you know those are the three
things I want to see out of my military
and I think that what we're bringing in
now is what drag shows and you know
transsexual you know uh AG gender
affirming surgeries and travel abortions
that's being paid for by the federal
government things like this that in no
way I mean what we should be thinking
about is how do we improve the quality
of life how do we get military
Construction milcon in place that allows
the housing availability and
affordability to be better for our our
Armed Forces how can we actually make
sure that instead of just having two
days a week for child care for the
spouses of those who serve we have it
all day every day so they can have
careers of their own like we should be
thinking about improving the quality of
life of our armed service members but
also let's start prioritizing our
veterans over illegal aliens who are
basically invading our nation I mean we
don't because American culture has
shifted into being sort of anti-military
I think that there's sort of a a a
disconnect between the way people used
to feel I mean this Administration has
almost become anti-American oh they're
they're anti military day-to-day
American person personality I mean you
see this reflected in military
recruitment recruitment people don't
want to join the military we 33,000
recruitment deficit right now I mean
you're talking three military divisions
yeah and meanwhile one of the Amendments
that I tried to pass that I tried to put
in that CBO the Congressional budget
office tried to say scored which is
nonsense I wanted us to basically look
at the fact that these vaccination
purging is unconstitutional and that we
should bring back our military service
members we should give them the back pay
that's necessary they shouldn't have to
pay any bonuses back because at the end
of the day they were to serve our
government or I should say serve our
nation not to serve our government's
agenda and so you know and meanwhile
they were like no sorry this scores so
you can't put it in as an amendment it's
it it it's just ridiculous what we're
seeing right now I I I guess I I have to
agree to some extent it is an
anti-military but
anti-American do you think there's a way
to shift culture away from that I mean
there's always going to be politicians
who are sort of anti-military or see you
know more conservative takes on the
military and conservative values uh a as
a threat but do the day-to-day Americans
ultimately want to say oh you're
returning vet I don't care about you
because that's really what a lot of you
said the exact thing in the earlier part
of your statement which is politicians
they're part of the they're actually the
biggest part of the problem we don't
need politicians we need Statesmen we
need veterans who've actually served in
uniform who understand exactly what our
war Fighters need to be able to move
forward we have to have the necessary
resources and assets not being
pre-allocated to another country to
where they can actually worry about the
PTSD and the the trauma the other
nations going through and ignoring our
own veterans here at home we have to
just get back to Statesmen who
understand what the America First
approach is and start prioritizing the
American citizens uh we have had Tom
sour on a couple days ago and he's like
privati he's taken it into his own hands
they have a private company it's mirar
health and they're wholly focused on
helping veterans rehabilitate themselves
through whatever kind of therapy whether
it's psych I think they're they're
they're looking into um Psy psychedelic
therapy as well like MDMA th it's a lot
of it's about communication about and I
I I don't think the government can
handle it I think it needs to be in the
private sector like the VA I don't know
a lot about it but all I hear complaints
about complaints for 20 years people
have been complaining about how
ineffective it is so I'm I don't know if
you it is ineffective and you know I'll
even go a step further you you the
problem with all of government is that
the metric of success is completely
skewed their idea by gauging what is a
metric of success is the idea of how
much should I spend and they continue to
try and say oh well we spent more this
year than we'd ever spent before Oh we
increased veterans by you know 20% oh we
did this what they're not doing is is
gauging about the true metric of how
many people did you actually help what
is the outcome in which we're looking at
where we're able to to say we went from
21 or 22 veteran suicides today down to
18 what was that cost in order to do
that because let me tell you if I could
get it down to zero give me that number
you know but you also have them where
they'll go ahead and say oh we just
built another VA Hospital well yeah you
just spent a billion dollars on this new
VA hospital in a metropolitan area that
already has nine other hospitals which
have the same exact levels of care why
wouldn't you put that to a rural area
where people can actually get treatment
and open it up to where all of our
veterans can basically utilize the
existing you know Medical Treatments and
Facilities that are actually existing
there already I mean this is the thing
veterans don't necessarily need to have
like a special hospital we there's
hospitals who offer a lot of these same
things but we do need them in the rural
communities we do need to understand how
do we treat and how do we give the
necessary resources and assets I mean
the the military veteran as a whole is
very traditional you know we believe in
things like being able to as as a man
for example the idea to be able to
protect my family to be able to provide
for my family and so when we come out
and we essentially have no way to supply
and you know keep up with the 40-year
high inflation and the cost of living
that's out of control and untenable or
we don't have the housing affordability
and availability for a soldier any
longer and so they don't feel like a man
because they can't protect and provide
for their family so that loses their
their their objective their mission
their focus and I think that then they
start chasing you know well something
must be wrong I'm getting into a
depressed state and here's the other
problem that we have to acknowledge the
pharmaceutical companies have continued
just with the doctors to want to
overprescribe and overmedicate every
single person think that that's the
solution they benefit when you're sick
and they can prescribe you something for
all the side effects that they have
caused but they want to keep you sick
for as long as possible because that's
how they actually make their M they
benefit when you're sick is that how it
is in the VA too they exactly how it is
oh you have an issue here's a script oh
that pain still bothering you and that
the last pain pills that we didn't give
you is enough let me increase the dosage
you know and I'm not saying that we
don't have great Medical Care Providers
but what we do have is we've got a
conflict of interest when you have
people who actually are able to you know
it's the same thing with you know
legislators who are able to trade in the
stock market even though they can make
legislation that manipulates the stock
price you have doctors who of course are
going to invest in the pharmaceutical
companies of the you know things that
they prescribe the most right because
they understand so there there's just a
lot that we have to fix in this country
but the first thing is we have to get
back to understanding what does it mean
to be on an America First agenda again
would you recommend joining the military
to like an 18-year-old today I you know
I would I mean look at the end of the
day we've got one of the strongest
greatest volunteer forces I was proud to
have served in form and I think it's a
great honor I think it's something that
if you're born with that servant
leadership heart and a lot of us you
know we used to joke that we must be
wired wrong right but the reality is
that you're just born with a servant
leadership heart you are or you're not
and the thing that why I ran you know
one of the big things was not just to
look out for our military veterans but
to ensure that our military has all the
ntion you know the resources the assets
and that they get back to the priorities
that they should be focused on so that
men and women can actually serve not
thinking about this woke agenda or this
Dei over meritocracy type of thing for
you know Equity over equality I mean
it's it's just this idea of us building
back our military on the principles and
the beliefs of what it originally
started from I want to introduce a super
soldier program where people can you can
be like yo you want to do experimental
gene therapy and be able to run three
times faster not have to breathe breathe
every eight eight minutes you want to
see 90 times further I hope you're
volunteering for it that's what I'm
talking about dude I will be the first
and like I but I think so many young
people maybe don't have a purpose and
like the idea that you could become a
badass and it would be it's all on you
cuz it may may not work it may work but
like you can sign up for this I think it
would increase have the X-Men I guess at
some point that's what I'm talking about
it's cuz it's happening anyway man in
China they're doing crisper they are
building super soldiers so why don't we
just do it
publicly we don't have to disclose all
the results I I honestly just wish that
we could even get back to the idea of
not having drag shows on our military
installations so you're you're Lighty
years ahead on that already you mention
I was going to say I feel like because
recruitment uh standards are so or like
we're not meeting recruitment goals
right now they're more likely to want to
lower all of the physical standards
rather than start recruiting for
potential super soldiers well I mean
look Al maybe you can make a super
soldier out of anybody I don't really
know how it works I always say that you
know one of the things that that that
plagues this nation is that we have a
crisis in leadership and you know the
issues that we're seeing right now yes
it does start at the commander-in chief
but it also I look at the Secretary of
Defense who I've actually issued
impeachment articles against and filed
those because of his you know handling
and D elction of Duty if you want to on
how Afghanistan went and the Bots
withdraw it cost 13 Brave Heroes their
lives and and I'm blessed that I'll be
I'll be with Paula canos who is the
mother of Ryan canos one of the 13 uh
brave soldiers who had died on August
26th I'll be with her December 13th
where uh we'll be going out in in
section 60 in Arlington to be able to go
ahead and visit her son and pay our
respects but you know there has to be
accountability again in government
that's what it matters Floyd Austin
Secretary of Defense and did he oversee
the surrender he oversaw a majority of
it let's let's let's jump to the story
from the New York Post and get into the
the the Crux of all of this this is is
uh a story that says Florida rep Cory
Mills flies to Israel to rescue 32
Americans trapped amid fighting but that
was October 12th uh that number is much
much higher and it's not just that you
uh uh flew missions to save people
rescue people in Israel is that
Afghanistan as well right so uh I'd like
to start with Afghanistan if you can
talk talk to us about what happened how
it happened what what what prompted you
to actually fly and start getting some
of these people out and then we can get
into obviously the Israel stuff so I I
get a call and I'd known Ronnie Jackson
for some time I mean this is a guy who's
a rear Admiral who served on the armed
services committee who's a a member of
Congress and literally he called me and
said Cory I I've got a problem he's like
you know I've tried to reach out to the
state department I tried to reach out to
the Department of Defense I've tried to
see what we could do to try and get some
of my constituents who are trapped in
Afghanistan who are being actively
hunted right now by the Taliban and and
I said well who is it you know and so he
disclosed who it was and it was a mother
and her three children you know a
15-year-old and 11-year-old little girl
a 15-year-old boy and a 2-year-old
little girl and uh he literally had no
idea how to get them out even though
here he is a member of Congress and he's
calling the right people who would have
jurisdiction and approval on this
Authority and the things that they were
telling him was absolutely false they
would tell him oh well she can just call
the state department and they'll direct
her and she did this time and time again
to no answer or she would text them you
know just to give you an idea when when
and I told Ronnie I said look I'm going
to go over there I said and I won't come
back until I get them and that's one of
the things that he's said multiple times
and you know we were attempted to be
thwarted in our efforts by the Biden
Administration multiple times I mean
even had them scramble an F16 to do a
fly over to try and intimidate us even
though we had approved Landing permits
on a PPR and we're in an American
aircraft with American former Special
Operations guys to save Americans and
it's our own government who's trying to
put us at risk but you know after 11
days we ended up conducting this this
successful Overland rescue which is the
first of its kind 2 and 1/2 weeks later
after Miriam and her children are are
already in in Amarillo Texas they're
already back in school she starts
receiving text messages from the state
department saying hey we're just
reaching out to you to see if you're
okay and find out where you're at in
Afghanistan they didn't even know that
she had been back safely I mean this is
the inept INF fecklessness of this
Administration this is the Der elction
of Duty by secretary Lloyd Austin by
Anthony blinkin the open borders under
mayorcas the weaponization under Garland
and Ray I mean all of these people need
to be held accountable but we don't do
anything but talk about we're more
likely to oust someone from our own
party than to go after the people who
are actually needing to be impeached I
mean like bman should be expelled for
the for the fire alarm thing but instead
it's George it's Santos who by the way
is the first person in history to not be
convicted of an actual crime and or
committed treason I mean look it's
happened five times before Santos three
people in 1861 which was right after the
Confederate you know that that that
deemed these individuals to be
treasonous and the other two who were
convicted felons and now you got a guy
who and this is why I voted against this
expulsion is that who are we to play
judge jur an executioner first off who
are we to not allow him due process to
be able to approach as accusers in his
day of court in front of a jury of his
peers because what this does in my
opinion is that I think that he has
every right to a potential appeal now
because I think that we have in some way
could potentially influenced the or Mis
or or started to lead the witnesses and
the jury in some way just by our actions
in Congress because now what we're
saying is is in America yeah you are
actually guilty until proven innocent
not innocent until proven guilty it's
going to Prejudice any jury pool because
this is National level politics can the
can Congress just expel anybody at any
time if they vote on it technically they
can okay so it was LE everything that
happened was above board but it just
like yeah but he's not convicted and
it's a weird precedent to set right it I
mean we just decided that we don't want
you here anymore there's not an actual
crime you should have to run that
through the senate or at least by the
American people well and and let me be
clear I'm not trying to defend anything
that George Santos has done but what I
am defending is is the rights to do
process for every single American I mean
what kind of Precedence does this set it
was basically the house what we have to
be thinking about the house Ethics
Committee report and decision was enough
for everyone to say okay let's good well
it wasn't everyone not everyone but for
the enough people to say okay we should
expel unfortunately but you also had
people like a lot of the New Yorkers who
were difficult positions because since
he's also from New York they felt that
they had to take action because they
were hearing it a lot from their
constituents but also here's my other
thing who are we in Congress to
basically make a decision to expel
someone who was elected by 750,000
people in their District yeah we should
allow the constituents to be able to do
their jobs and to be able to go ahead
and carry out their civic duties and
again this for me is more about
protecting your sixth amendment more
about protecting the rule of law you
know and and due process but also
protecting the vote of constituents so
that they can actually have the rights
to elect or not elect whomever they
choose yeah it sounds like it's become a
little bit too much of a social club of
people that think they're Elite and they
can just I mean technically they can
still kick each other out but I do think
that that it's like you don't like my
guy well he's my guy well think about it
Jamal Bowman admits to doing something
wrong while a member of Congress commit
a crime and actually is charged for that
he gets censured a guy who does
something which was previous in most
cases of what his indictments for the
grand jury is being accused of in my
understanding is prior to coming in
and has not yet been prosecuted for it
but he gets expelled is it just legit we
have Bowman on camera if they were going
to expel someone before a conviction
Bowman I would understand as as being
reasonable because he's on camera I I
don't even justify that whether it's on
camera or not we should allow the due
process to be there we we can't say that
we again are being judged during an
execution or based on our observance You
Are Not Guilty by the observations in
which you make you are guilty by the
rendered Verdict by either the Judgment
of a judge who we appoint for solid
reasons or the jury which actually finds
their their peer guilty I mean we just
have to understand We're a nation which
is based on the rule of law we're a
constitutional republic and we have to
not continue to water that down and
dilute it just because it's beneficial
for us you've got you brought up the the
impeachment of of secretary defense
secretary defense Lloyd Austin and he
was result he was basically largely
responsible for the surrender of the
American Military the secretary of state
so what would an impeachment look like
what would be the charges and how would
that play out I my my charge on him was
the D election of Duty I mean the simple
fact that he has a role to play and a
job to do you had soldiers who were
deployed who had no rules of engagement
no understanding of what their
authorization of force was I mean
there's people who could have actually
in one case uh a guy named uh Tyler
Vargas Andrews I believe is his name or
Tyler Andrew Vargas always mess this up
um but he was uh badly injured uh and is
an ampute as a result of the explosion
he was the sniper who was in the tower
who actually had identified the
potential suicide bomber had called back
what he appeared to be the identificated
bolo which is the be on the lookout had
it verified was asking for a green light
to be able to engage and never receive a
green light from IND his command because
they didn't know who actually had the
authority to give that moments later the
explosion goes off 13 Brave members have
lost their lives these are things where
you should have an escalation of force
and a Rules of Engagement that's
established prior to them even being
deployed you should have an
understanding what was going on and so
this was completely just botched from
the very beginning and the fact that
there's no one who's been held
accountable and look when I think about
accountability I think about it as you
lead by example and so it's for me I
used to call it the concept of Windows
and mirrors when something is being done
properly and everything is going
successfully you look through the window
at all those outside who are actually
delivering on that but when something
goes wrong as a leader you have to look
in the mirror because ultimately it's on
you this seems like a pattern though I
mean there are several Republicans I
think Andy bigs and or is it bigs or
Briggs from Arizona he brought der
elction of Duty impeachment uh charges
against uh mayorcas absolutely for the
Border because the's a mess but it
anyway can argue that's not no may orcus
could definitely be impeached but we
haven't gotten it yet I mean there is
there are lots of members of the in
Biden Administration who I would believe
are uh are derelict in duty but they are
still in office at what point do we get
some action I mean it mustan this is
what frustrates me and obviously you
know the one thing that I agree with is
that we and 18th Congress brought back
through our conference rules the regular
order which means that everything has to
go through its Committee of jurisdiction
and then come out of that and then come
to the house floor but I mean look if we
can't even at least start the
impeachment process why can't we utilize
things like the H in act where we
basically take the salary of those
individuals and we drop it down to $1 a
year you know these people shouldn't be
getting paid when they actually aren't
doing the job that they were actually
put in place to do and so until they can
actually have an impeachment inquiry and
then trial and be have have the
depositions in place at a minimum just
like if a person in a regular you know I
think about this from from the regular
world if you do something wrong in a job
and they're investigating what you did
wrong in many cases you get an ABS you
basically get leave you know uh from the
job for a certain period of time but
you're not being paid during that time
you haven't lost your job yet you can
also go to jail before you've been
convicted that that's exactly right see
my whole point is is that at least with
the homean rule we could at least
dropped his salary down to $1 while we
continue to investigate and some
propos we could suspend Bowman pending a
conviction on the uh on the on the thing
with the doors the fire alarm very
possible what's the the home will they
and they won't that's that's the problem
I mean look You' got someone on on on
camera committing a crime I think it's a
good point he should be convicted but at
the same time there's a reasonable step
between okay someone's been accused of a
crime and there's a preponderance of
evidence that they may be violent so
we're going to hold them right if
they're if they're found to be not
guilty we release them and we're
supposed to have hearings for this if
there is someone who there is no prance
of evidence he's been accused well then
you don't even get an indictment but if
you do then the person is going to be
free on bail that's right so considering
Santos he's been accused they say
there's evidence okay well you're gonna
have to prove that for uh uh Bowman he
lied about what he did the camera proves
he lied and he committed a crime I would
I would think I would say it's fair to
suspend him pending a res a resolution
it's this the Homan rule so how do you
enact to the Homan rule uh it's
essentially a privilege resolution I
believe that you could put on the floor
but uh uh last time that we've actually
well we've tried it multiple times by a
lot of us who are true constitutional
conservatives who believe in
accountability of government and it
wouldn't get the votes okay so it's just
a one bill one vote kind of thing I mean
yeah with some of these things like like
I mentioned uh potentially impeaching
Alandra mayoras do you think there's a
point where Democrats would see yes the
border is a disaster well I mean I think
that you even see that from New York
city mayor Adams right I me he's even
crying about it and these it's funny
that now the sanctuary cities oh come on
in we're inv fting you in oh come on
in like this is actually a problem I
mean DC has said we need help but they
haven't actually well DC said they
needed help but only after we had to
pass things like the DC crime Bill to
stop the soft on crime Catch and Release
policies of you know these woke and
these these liberal extreme Mayors like
Muriel Bowser or you know even even ni
Eric Adams or any of the rest but like
my whole point is is that there's more
than enough circumstantial evidence for
us to be able to move forward with
impeachment articles against if anyone
anyone
it's secretary my orcus cuz we get the
CBP reports I mean you're seeing the
record high numbers that are coming
across you're seeing an increase in the
number who are actually coming across
that are on terrorist watch lists I mean
this is the whole thing and this isn't
people from South America and that's
what people understand you know 63 to
6,400 Afghans I mean 32,000 plus you
know Chinese from mainland China you've
got people from Yemen you've got people
from uh Saudi Arabia you got I mean
there is a dozen plus different
countries who are coming through our
Southern borders and I don't think that
we can say the Secretary of my orcus is
doing anything to actually prevent that
because in fact he's the same one that
went on record to say we don't have open
borders right you know it it just and
the bid Administration will say we're
doing the best job ever on the border
well but here's here's a great thing in
the hypocrisy of the bid Administration
they'll tell you that they had to repeal
remain in Mexico agreement or that they
had removed title 42 but then they'll
come back to you and say oh the entire
failed Afghan withdrawal we couldn't do
anything about it it was already in
motion because of the Trump
Administration you know it it's just it
the hypocrisy and the lies that come out
this Administration is just something
I've never seen in my lifetime yeah that
if they call it a failed withdraw they
should re retitle that a surrender
because that's what that was a
disgusting surrender to the strongest
military on Earth surrendered to the
Taliban not to mention the billions of
dollars that we left behind in weapons
defense articles and we put terrorist
organizations like the Taliban the hakan
network and Isis corsan in a better
position now than they're ever were
before and let's go back why did we go
into Afghanistan 2001 it was because we
wanted to stop it from being a safe
haven or a harbor for terrorism
meanwhile fast forward to the bid
Administration where we actually left
them after what I would argue still that
George W bush and even Obama had these
failed approaches that we can do nation
building which is not our role we're not
there to build the nation of others
we're there to basically eliminate
terrorists who are actually a threat to
America and come back home to protect
our homelands but you know let's fast
forward that to the point that we did
the opposite of what we said that we
were going there to do we actually
emboldened and strengthened and armed
and trained and even left enough cash to
create the calip if they want the
opposite of what the intent was that's
why I'm I I'm not satisfied with uh
surrender I think that's going too easy
on them I don't I don't understand how
you abandon bam without informing the
security forces I think it's treas in
what they've done yeah I agree that
again a surrender would be like okay let
let our forces know we're we're out
something else is when we have never we
have never pulled our military in our
history we've never pulled our military
before we ensured the safety of
civilians first I mean the idea that
we're going to pull our military before
we even try and make sure that American
citizens are out first to be saved but
why but the BAM thing gets me because we
we could have evacuated through bam
absolutely we could have Okay so let's
say I've been to Bam multiple times you
you could have here's the other big
thing that you have to understand we
could have simultaneously run two
separate airports right you could allow
the continuation of the civilian hkaya
that was going on and you could have
gone ahead and utilized which by the way
could have housed 40 plus thousand
people we could have done the necessary
Biometrics Health scans to look at our
sivs and others who are actually had
served with for over 20 plus years
risking their lives instead of just
abandoning and leaving them behind who
are being now methodically killed you
know one by one but the other thing is
that what did it have it had an entire
military installation of parameter
standoff so what ended up happening and
this is where the Biden Administration
hasn't been answering for this yet when
they shut down BM to hand it over to
China and they went ahead and allowed
the BM prison which released over 40,000
terrorists who had actually already been
incarcerated there to be released yes
who had been which basically plused up
the entire force that was already coming
in now what else did you do when you
take a military takeover of a civilian
uh uh airport all of those flights
because they were telling all the
Americans you have to be out by
September 11th he wanted to tout this
great Victory on this day but when he
shut it down premature to that all the
people who had civilian flights out on
Ariana cam air Emirates you name it
those air liners got completely canceled
so there was no more calm air that could
come in and come out so they essentially
entrapped Americans by shutting down the
civilian airport and giving them no Safe
Harbor to be able to get out I I pulled
up the name it's Tyler Vargas Andrews
he's the dude absolute hero he was in a
tower you were saying and then they were
surrounded or they were people coming at
them they had already been told that day
of what the bolo was which is be on the
lookout of the individual what he'd be
wearing what it be carrying a satchel
you know these types of things he while
he was up there in the tower identified
an individual who fit that description
who he believes is the actual bomber the
suicide bomber he then relayed that
information back and someone came to the
tower to confirm exactly what he saw
from I believe it was the scaps
Battalion that was there and they
confirmed what he saw and then he asked
for green light to engage and no one in
his command or even at higher command
knew who could actually provide that
Authority so no one gave him the
authority moments later explosion occurs
and we saw what happened first thing he
did a show on Sean Ryan it's spectacular
and Tyler's awesome and it's like 5 and
a half hours long and everyone should go
watch that the guy's amazing so is this
like obsessive centralized Control
Authority thing like new is it normal
because I would think you'd have
somewhere in the lower levels of command
that are like at least equipped to give
you an order or to respond to your
request for for Action well you usually
in every scenario I've ever seen you
always have command who can actually
issue that Authority and you always have
an clear understanding of what your
rules of engagement are what the
escalation of force is and the bottom
line is is that this was AA a chaotic
botch withdrawal that endangered
American lives and I can tell you that
secretary blinkin was even given a cable
a diplomatic cable with 23 members of
The Diplomatic Corps who warned him
about this strategy saying Americans
would die they tried to hide that from
our Foreign Affairs committee until the
point that we actually were trying to
subpoena uh chairman McCall was
subpoenaing Anthony blinkin for the fact
that he wouldn't and refused without the
redacted lines on it which was basically
the entire document to show this but
here's what we ended up asking we asked
a woman who had been responsible for
filing those types of cables and we said
and your entire time and she was almost
done with her career I think she had 17
plus years have you ever seen how many
of these cables do you get a year what
they call a descent cable and she said
somewhere between maybe one two a year
on average and we said okay great how
many people usually are signatory Ries
on these documents and they said one
maybe two people and I said so it didn't
send a red flag when he had
23 people who are part of the Diplomatic
core of the state department who signed
this descent cable warning about this
withdrawal prior to it happening so all
the signs were there all the intel was
there there was Intel reports by the way
that even demonstrated who and when and
what was going to happen they even I
mean to the point where the days before
they would say okay these individuals
are moving from this city to this city
next day they're now in the city next
day they're in a planning phase next day
they're now done with the plan here's
how it's going to be carried out and
then boom the next day it occurred so
linkoln and Austin can't say that they
didn't have the details and the
information on how to prevent this they
are responsible and there's blood on
their hands and there has to be
accountability I I don't think it's a
strategy I I don't see any reasonable
argument for abandoning bom it doesn't
it doesn't make sense it it does the
only reason you would do that is to
create chaos disorder and intentionally
get people killed or unless China and
others are trying to tell you that you
need to go right now because you're a
compromised and corrupted Administration
and you're now leaving by the way $1.1
trillion in lithium so you sitting in
paner you think there's comprom on Biden
or the administration China says we're
taking the base we're taking the country
and you're getting the F out who's the
first person who recognizes Taliban is
an actual form of government Chinese
China's moving in they're going for the
lithium mines 100% I it could also
be it could be it could be comprom but
could it also be Biden just
selling for a minute just put this
together you're now handing over a
country putting Americans at lives so
that the the Chinese can get to $1.1
trillion in in potential lithium and at
the same time what are you pushing for
you're pushing for an EV system which is
based out of lithium Cobalt and nickel
which is all produced by China to build
their economy you the these are not and
this is where you know being a
geopolitical analyst for a long time you
don't look at everything so singularly
you start making the link analysis of
look this is not a one-off look and and
you know this it's not just kind of this
coincidence you know in police work they
call them Clues and so what we have to
understand is is that that's exactly
what is going on is that we are driven
towards building China's economy and
going to a more China One you know
foreign first policy as opposed to an
America First policy where we actually
look out for our own and that's that's
because of the corruption and that's
because of what you're seeing being
released by chairman James comr chairman
Jim Jordan chairman uh uh Jason Smith
where they're showing the multitude of
layers of corruption and the spiderwebs
of companies and the continuation of
this temp % for the big guy and the
millions upon millions of dollars that
Jim and Haley and Hunter and all them
are getting look the this is the most
corrupt and most bought and paid for pay
forplay Administration that I've ever
seen in my lifetime so what do we do man
we impeach his ass Joe Biden I'm down we
hold accountability we return the power
back to the American people we start
actually being true constitutionalists
who understand that our overspending
which in my I've talked about this
previous when we're on the you know
going into the show but you know we're
running into an economic abyss and we
keep acting like we can cut our way to
Prosperity you can't ask any business
owner out there if you can cut your way
to profitability you can't your account
receivables have to exceed your account
payables and if they don't then you're
ins solving as a business the difference
is as a business when you have to go and
get a line of credit or you have to go
to a bank you have to prove your ability
to actually pay it back well American
government does is they utilize the
American people as a taxpayer who is the
bank but they don't have to justify how
they actually pay it back they don't
have to actually show a business plan on
what they're actually doing and they
think they can cut their way to
Prosperity as opposed to focusing on
what they need to which is proper reform
on the nearly 73% of mandatory spending
that is going on understanding you have
to have a cut strategy which yes that is
part of it to try and make sure that
programs and things that we're spending
on is no longer you know doing their
purpose or serving their purpose is
eliminated but also an economic growth
strategy that allows us to understand
how do we get that GDP P to national
debt inverted ratio back to a point
where we could even be stable one but
also where we can back it by tangible
assets that allow our dollar and our
currency to have confidence across the
global market for even the developing
nations that are utilizing it who's
co-sponsoring your impeachment Bill uh
with the uh Lloyd Austin yeah we had
quite a few signatures on there yeah
anyone who you want weren't expecting to
jump on no actually it's exactly the
type of America First conservatives that
you would imagine F you gave me some
crazy numbers before we went live about
what our dollar every dollar the
government borrows it's what 70 so this
continues to change obviously as as you
know every second we get more but
essentially think about it from this
perspective right when you hear your
representative or your Senator talk
about how they're making the biggest
cuts ever to spending I want to get an
understanding of what that means every
dollar that we borrow roughly 73 cents
of that we'll call it 70 cents 70 cents
of that is spent already just on the
mandat spendings and then as our debt
continues to increase as the actual
interest rates on that debt continues to
increase roughly right now around 11
cents of every single dollar is just
servicing our interest payments and then
you look at our defense spending which I
think we can argue you know with with
good understanding that we need a strong
military that's 13 14 cents of every
dollar you know at 860 to 870 billion
that we're spending on our military per
year which is needed because we don't
even have our our necessary classes for
the Columbus class and things like that
for our submarines and others but that's
spent just about which means that your
representative your Senator the person
that's telling you we're making these
massive Cuts what they're talking about
is we're taking a 20% a 30% cut yeah
you're right a 20 to 30% cut on the
remaining nine cents or so that you can
actually touch which in the scheme of
things those cents that you're cutting
on that is not going to get us again
you're not cutting your way to
Prosperity without having an economic
growth strategy without decoupling
ourselves away ad away from the
adversarial Nations without getting
control of our supply chain our
resources and rare earth minerals that
are necessary for us to support an
industrial based buildout we're not
going to be able to do this based on DC
status quo that we're going to spend our
way out of this or we're going to be cut
our way to prosperity it's a lie the you
you the numbers add up to like 95% of
every dollar we borrow is automatically
spent so of that less five these are
rough numbers of the remaining 5% if
they cut 20 % of that 5 cents and it's
like one cent or less you're still not
getting your way to a way of prosperity
and they'll tell people they're cutting
20% of the of the budget of the of the
spending but it's only F of the five
cents on a dollar they're cutting 20% of
the 5 cents that's that's like less than
five1 of a cent I don't percent like
okay so that's crazy now let's talk
about GDP growth you told me before the
show you believe it's energy I think
it's energy I think we should transition
it into a hydrogen-based fuel economy
I'm I'm bullish on this coming out of
rice University they're making hydrogen
gas out of recovered carbon trash hit it
with electricity at 7,000 de they flash
it turn it into hydrogen fuel they're
left over with $4.50 of this so let's
jump that though how many how many oil
refineries are in the United States Cory
might know better than I do we haven't
built an oil refinery since like the
1970s no no but but yeah but how many do
we have I think what two or three is
that it I think soan IDE I really could
I really don't know the exact number on
that but uh I can tell you we haven't
built a Refinery since I believe it was
the 70s but the bottom line is that
here's the issue I I don't think that's
it's an either or and you always hear
this from the left and the right you
know I'm all for the idea of drill baby
drill look trust me I I like the idea of
continuing to produce fossil fuels
looking at LNG uh I like the idea of us
basically continuing to look and explore
Renewables looking at nuclear which by
the way is the cleanest safest everyone
wants to argue 9M island or Chernobyl or
you know the the uh issue that happened
in in the I can't remember the name of
the Japanese reactor that was Fukushima
I got a I got a fact check for you yeah
the last Refinery was built in February
2022 there are currently 129 operating
in the United States that's a lot more
than I actually anticipated but it does
look like it's you know maybe one every
decade or so one every uh eight years
what do they say it definitely doesn't
keep up with our current growth and what
our utilization is I mean but but going
back to my point of the renewable
reliable argument it it has to be both
we have to be able to look at multiple
things but we have to understand that if
we're going to basically go off of this
you know gold standard which we did I
believe it was around 1971 or 1973 I
can't recall and go to the Petro dollar
that dollar has to be backed by some
type of a tangible production and that
right there because to your point on the
GDP we had passed hr1 which was a bill
that Steve scis put onto the floor which
is the lowcost energy act which
basically gets us back to a more energy
dominant position but at the same time
we passed hr21 which would prevent the
president from draining down our
strategic petroleum reserves that he has
actually done at a record level that
we've never seen before for so if we go
to this and we start actually producing
energy and we back our Dollar by this in
the way that we should then every single
time if especially if we look at energy
output because I agree with you Ian in
this the Global Currency which is the
whole point China Russia Iran and North
Korea have continued to modify their
constitution to stay in power forever
because they want to do what they want
to eliminate the US dollar from the
Global Currency they want to throw us on
hyperinflation they want to utilize the
corruption of wh and wef who by the way
I co-sponsor the bill with chip Roy that
would actually stop us from dir
indirectly even funding any of the who I
think it's a complete you know uh farce
but my whole thing is is that we have to
start basing our valuation our spending
cap on what our energy production is
which also would incentivize every
president on the left and the right to
produce as much as possible to have the
most spending levers but it would weaken
OPEC who when they try and threaten us
and say we're cutting our production by
100,000 barrels we go oh great so the
price of oil goes up we have more money
to spend great thanks for that so my
whole thing is is you decouple away from
the utilization but also things like us
Aid where we continue to utilize cash
diplomacy where we're sending for
example $800 million to a country that
absolutely hates us and we think that's
going to turn around and they're going
to go you know what we love you now
America no they're going to say we still
hate you but we're 800 Million Dollar on
taxpayers money richer we're like
divorce dads trying to bribe kids and
Ling us corre and not only that but
think about it and I don't like to to to
build up anything that another nation is
doing that's kind of an adversary of us
but what Russia did with Germany was
convince them to get rid of after 20
years all their nuclear and Coal Energy
and be completely dependent upon them we
could actually stop cash diplomacy under
us Aid Supply lowcost reliable energy to
developing nations which would also
ensure that they continue to stay on
side with America but also guess what
it's Revenue coming into the US it's not
us pouring tax money dollars into
another nation and continue to send
things out yeah the Petro dollar needs
to be convered to a hydrogen dollar I I
know we can do it and the oil Industries
all you execs out there listening will
turn your oil into graphine and we're
not going to stop d it's going to get
even better okay so so the reason I
asked about how many refineries there
were is because first before we're going
to transition the US economy in from oil
to hydrogen you need comparable energy
production for which you are able to do
it true right now one of the big
challenges with electric vehicles for
instance is charging them and so uh what
what you hear a lot about is
batteries what's the range on the
vehicle actually range is no issue for
us so with the Tesla you you park it you
charge it you never drive far enough to
where we even care about what the charge
is because once you bring it home it's
charging the issue is if you want to
travel far you need to be able to refill
it very quickly so you do need Good
batteries but uh so so adoption is going
to be is going to come from expansion
technology now as for like hydrogen
fuels and fusion or anything else
someone's going to have to be able to
run their car off of hydrogen hydrogen
energy which is go which is going going
to require an EV we are not even at the
point where people can use EVS reliably
because gas you fill up your car in 30
seconds some safely right because we saw
where like in Florida for example we
were having floods
and these batteries were essentially
they were blowing up endangering people
so we we really need to think about also
just the safety and reliability and and
R Ronnie Jackson said this the best he
said look it's a simple thing I'll take
reliable over renewable and and and
again I think that has to be both I
think we have to be able to have an
understanding and a choice for every
single americ which why you know we just
voted down by the way you know the bid
Administration wanted to force every
American by 2032 to go completely to EV
and luckily we in the house I don't know
what the Senate will do with this we
voted it down because we believe that
just like whether it's medical Freedom
whether it's school choice whether it's
we are supposed to be providing Freedom
Liberty and protection of the rights of
every American people not telling them
you need more government in your life
the the issue with the Renewables is
that they're as you described not as
reliable so with uh chemical energy with
petroleum the reason why I don't see the
US getting off of a a petroleum economy
is because it is a dense extremely dense
chemical storage of energy which can be
utilized whenever yeah it's fuel there's
only three elements that can function as
fuel it's hydrogen carbon and um
plutonium and so we're using the carbon
in the oil but we can use the hydrogen
fuel it's just transportable if you can
put it in a box and move it around it
becomes a fuel like producing steam is
not fuel but but the issue is with you
know so so there's theoretically
hydrogen cell you can do hydrogen tanks
in cars and if those could charge the
batteries and so but but you no you
could do hydrogen comp Vehicles which
people have and they're really cheap to
operate or or natural gas cars and then
you need to retrofit every single gas
station and you need to build the
refineries or you can build engines that
are hybrid hydrogen petroleum engines
and so you could use either I think
that's where we're going end of the day
you know what I want I want people to be
able to heat and cool their houses at a
fraction of what they're using right now
I want fuel prices for whatever it is
that you drive to be affordable for
every single individual and I want us to
get away from the idea that we're
continuing to stay reliant on
adversarial Nations how we get there I
I'm I'm less concerned with as much as
needing to get there and finding the
solutions I want to jump to the story
from barens US military holds exercises
exercises in Guyana as border tensions
sore oh boy I'm glad the US is down
there as Venezuela is building up its
military on their Eastern Front because
they're claiming basically half the
country of Guyana as their territory why
Exxon discovered a bunch of oil so the
US of course is down there Guyana has
asked for us uh the us to help prevent a
Venezuelan invasion of Guyana Venezuela
of course just sees dollar signs well
not necessarily dollar sign they're one
of
thethy they're the most resource wealthy
in South America they got o Venezuela
now they want to steal more so I guess
the two big issues here are welcome to
the issue of you're never going to get
off oil because it is just too valuable
it is it is it is Rel relative to
hydrogen or nuclear it's easy to get
it's easy to use it you can it can be
stored and easy containers it is
absolutely amazing and I don't want to
get off of it I just want to build
alternate systems that we can use in
conjunction with it cuz Plastics I mean
I don't I mean maybe we can make better
Plastics with carbon but with graphine
you know you can upscale these things
into better materials but oil is
incredible it is very valuable right and
but so the subject I want to get into is
uh you think we're going to get into
another War you think war is spreading
out of South America look I I would say
that weakness invites aggression and we
have to acknowledge that the bid
Administration has continued to
demonstrate this weakness in the world
stage which is why are where we are I
think that all of our enemies and our
adversarial Nations again you know if
you go back I I wrote about this years
ago about the Russia China Iran and
North Korea and geopolitical Alignment
you know they're utilizing not just
their uh alignment to try and go ahead
and expand out the belt and Road
initiative or to take the 15 of 16 rare
Earth mineral mines but to expose us and
drag us into these Quagmire Wars where
we can continue to drain down on what we
have as far as defense articles within
our own storage capacity and
capabilities what are they they're they
testing for their own intelligence what
our industrial base can actually
withstand with regards to production
capacity and capability and whether we
could actually you know stand up to an
actual largescale uh War but they're
continuing to also drag us into areas
because think about it Venezuela is
partnered in it's a marage convenience
with Russia we were actually starting to
focus a lot on the belt and Road
initiative expansion by looking at
certain types of a sanction or looking
at certain types of a internationally
recommended Transit Corridor for supply
chain stuff what what what China is
trying to achieve is this and that's why
and it does play into this and I I'll
explain this how they essentially want
to take this belt and Road initiative
which expands the Eurasian border takes
Africa and Oceania and that would cut
off Western Hemisphere supply chain
whether it's the Red Sea Mediterranean
Black Sea Persian Gulf corn of Africa
while simultaneously utilizing this
marriage convenience with Russia to take
Venezuela with the shabas of Venezuela
Pedro and Colombia and then look at
economic coercion in countries like
Panama and Honduras so they can actually
also start taking over the trade tariff
taxes and everything on the Panama Canal
so they could also pinch us there but
they had to draw us away from what they
were doing in that built and Road
initiative by actually focusing in our
own Western Hemisphere I mean look
they're also in addition to all the
things that's going on here they are
also building up the largest joint
training spy Base in Cuba which is an
impact to me as a Florida resident who
is 90 mies off my Shore and so this
issue that we're seeing in Venezuela is
nothing more than that continuation of
that belt and Road initiative over that
geopolitical alignment between China and
Russia where they're trying to draw us
into more of this while they continue to
do a resource grab and to your point
earlier to tie this in a bow that's
because it's not about the US dollar as
the global currency or the ri or the
dinar or the Yen or the ruble or
whatever energy is the global currency
and who has the most wins specifically
fuel it's fuel because energy can be
produced locally but can't be
transported like nuclear power plants
can't transport properly to Afghanistan
whereas fuel can be picked up lifted and
move pretty simple get our GDP to
national debt ratio inverted secure our
borders stop the wokeism get our
industrial base build out start thinking
about energy dominance we have to start
just thinking about the priorities of of
government do you think that the US
could handle a large scale War right now
I think that we could handle a large
scale War but I don't think that America
is ready for a large scale War what
distinction are you making well I look
at what our industrial based capacity
and capabilities are as far as buildout
I look at the fact that we're already
spread so thin and trying to continue to
this as I talked at and I kind of
ridiculed which rightfully so in my
opinion this neoconservative neoliberal
1980s style you know of of
interventionist ideologies that we have
to be involved in every war and we have
to actually go and make it from a
kinetic perspective um I I think that we
showed our hand the other day whenever
and I voted against it obviously but we
voted on sending cluster Munitions over
to Ukraine do you know why we actually
were starting to dump our storage with
cluster ammunitions because and this is
something that's been banned by over 100
different nations because you have a
roughly 1 to 5% I know it's a wide range
but depending on the producer 1 to 5%
dud ratio which means that you have more
uxo which means you're going to have
larger civilian casualties at at the end
of it and so we stopped utilizing the
Clusters but we did that because our
industrial based with the resources and
you know the capabilities couldn't keep
up with what was necessary for the high
Mars and attack thems and the other
areas for5 artillery shells things like
this and we're starting to get into what
we call our requirement which is our own
munition requirements and starting to
drill into that and so you know we're
showing and again this is the Brilliance
of what China and others are doing which
is that they're exposing some of the
weaknesses by dragging us into Wars that
they're not paying a dime on to try and
go ahead and look at where our
weaknesses are so that if they do choose
to take Taiwan or they do Tres to go
ahead and bring us into the Western
Hemisphere into Guyana or to into these
things that we actually they know what
our capability capacities are and so um
you know we have to be better and we
also have to understand domestic and
foreign policy is intrinsically linked
what we do domestically impacts us
internationally and vice versa and so
it's really important for us to try and
understand that we have to get our
supply chain back we have to get our
resources back we have to start actually
harvesting oursel I personally am a big
fan of the idea of doing deep seabed
harvesting you know the Earth is 70%
water and there are more natural
resources not talking about drilling
just talking about deep seabed
harvesting mineral harvesting there is
more at the 10,000 12,000 meter depth
levels than what you could find in these
15 of 16 rare mineral minds that China
has and China by the way controls 100%
of maganese production across the world
were you sorry I'm going to PIV it
slightly but were you always a
conservative or did your time in the
military sort of shift your perspective
I have been a registered Republican my
whole life and a constitutionalist my
whole life you know look I I tell people
all the time the only reason I'm a
registered Republican is because we're
stuck in this two- party system and
that's the one that essentially is the
closest to my conservative values right
it's not 100% aligned I think that we've
gotten away fromal registered uh
registered with with a party to vote in
a primary in Florida no I mean I grew up
in Connecticut and you did so I
registered as Republic a lot of npas
they are excluded from primaries but my
reasoning was is that you know there was
times when we actually had great
Republican members you know we still
have some today not to say that we don't
but I also think that what and you know
we're seeing a mass exodus by the way
you know of members from Congress it's
weird but it's actually you know I I
think it's a good thing and I'll tell
you why it doesn't sound good because it
doesn't have the numbers that we need
but we're ushering in a new generation
of conservative and we have evolved back
to the ways of being a true
constitutionalist being a fiscal
conservative understanding that we
represent the American people being a
Statesman not a politician look I've
been called almost everything in the
world the most derogatory term that you
can call me as a politician so you know
my whole thing is I just want to get
back to We the People and I think the
only way you do that is through limited
government and an understanding of what
actually is the America First agenda and
so this is where president Trump and
I've endorsed him from a long time ago
um I believe he's exactly what we need
need the nation right now to get us back
on track to make those bold course
Corrections yeah you said deep resour
deep sea resource harvesting deep seaes
that work is that like with drones you
can do it with drones and here's the
great part I still think that we should
be utilizing the quantum space where you
know for example do you remember when
Reagan had bankrupted the Soviet Union
with the Space Race no I didn't know he
did that yeah so we should be also
thinking about the idea of how can we
actually get China involved in a in a
Quantum race whereby they also because
their economy is worse than ours it's
just that the reason that people still
prop up their currency is because they
don't allow their books to be audited
they lie about what they actually spend
and what they actually have and so we
could try and corrupt and bankrupt or
corrupt we should try and bankrupt them
through a Quantum race whereby you know
being the first to have ai self-healing
autonomous drones utilizing like Quantum
linkage you know would be something that
we were try to advance in you know again
the idea is is that if you could get
something in a swarm drone technology
through uh Quantum linkage that uh
essentially is beneath their satellites
but above their
GSM Tower providers you could kind of
leave someone blind de and dumb on the
battlefield we cre to communicate
through Crystal so you know the idea is
that I think that there's ways for us to
start thinking about and this this is
why I argue again it's not just looking
at kinetic Warfare but it's thinking
about the ideas of economic resource
supply chain cyber and Quantum races
that is the actual way not to include or
not to not to miss out the fact that
it's also the information and propaganda
and information campaigns that are going
on what makes me nervous with qu with
artificial intelligence autonomous
drones with weapons as if they get
hacked I mean obviously that's the the
threat and and I'm sure China's going
through the same thing right now but the
thing is I guess whoever builds it first
and if you've got Quantum encryption you
know the quantum encryption race also is
insane because whoever gets that can
crack open all the bank records of
everyone in the country and release them
all the next day well the speed in which
and the capacity of quantum data
Computing is just but I I agree with you
we do need that race because it's
dangerous to have autonomous artificial
intelligent drones with lasers but
there's that's where it's headed so like
we need to to win the race yeah that
quantum entanglement that that that
everyone's trying to rush towards I want
to ask you if you expected Kevin
McCarthy to resign I actually didn't I I
didn't know it was going to take him
this long yeah so you were like well
he's saying end of the month no no what
I'm wondering is like did you guys have
a poll going and you were like well we
we they did the squares we wer we
weren't doing calendar Bingo but I I I
can tell you that yeah I assume you're
not all against the rules or because no
no just because I well we had do when
when it was announced was the was the
pizza party uh held for lunch or
dinner I I I I I think instead of a
pizza party everyone was probably
there's probably quite a few offices
that was uh a toasting and cheering and
I don't think anybody honestly I don't
nobody cares like the news broke and we
kind of just Shrugged and but then again
you you have people who are still in
office right now who are just a we still
want him as Speaker we're not willing to
give up we're not I mean so too bad and
McKenry announced the day before and
they were supposed to be sort of allies
right so it seems like there is an exit
like an I like Patrick you know Patrick
McKenry he was always getting ready I
mean he's at the end of his his ability
for chairmanship and the financial
services anyway but a really smart guy I
mean truly truly a smart guy um I mean
he still has another year to go he
doesn't leave no he's not going to just
try and abandon the seat um you know
I'll tell you though and and they can
think what they want but I thought the
the tweet that broke the cycle for me uh
a few days ago was by Matt Gates when he
tweeted out Mick
Len Mick L yeah was like a little
tagline you saw the the community note
on his tweet say where he was like I
will never quit and then it was
Community not said he just quit that's
Comm note on his tweet saying he
wouldn't was he disliked I mean this is
all anecdotal I don't know if you can
really answer he point a lot of people
to like him so I mean did or did I mean
every's a really nice guy like cool and
personable in person but just wasn't
getting the job done well look at no no
he was getting the job done for for the
other people for the corporations and
for the lobbyists right well you know at
the end of the day I think that
if we could have actually achieved what
we had originally agreed upon in the
first conference rule agreements you
know when we came out where we are going
to do regular order we are going to have
certain priorities of you know getting
things done for for me what really just
kind of uh broke confidence and and
capabilities was when we had the debt
ceiling debate you know I was all for
the idea once we had gotten permanent
reform in place and the Reigns act would
stop overregulation of the private
sector and we had a very fixed number at
1.47 one of spending cap which would
have been a very good spending level CU
that would have been pre-co
pre-emergency 2019 spending levels I
understood the intent of that because we
were going to try and do a Policy rider
with hr2 to also secure our borders when
we appr approved that we got that passed
when it went to the Senate and what came
back was that absolute just complete
acques with the physical what they call
physical responsibility which is
physical irresponsibility act that
basically took the 20 plus permit
reforms down to four that stripped out
cat cck's Reigns act which would have
stopped because I'm one of those odd
individuals who believe that the private
sector should be driving policy more so
than policy driving the private sector
but also the fact is is that it's not as
if we have a lack of legislation we have
a lack of the ability and the
willingness to enforce existing
legislation but every single member of
Congress wants their name on a p on on a
piece of legislation everyone wants to
try and play political football instead
of going back and looking at certain
bills that no longer serve their
purposes and looking at reforms as
opposed to just continuations of these
vague and AR ambiguous you know bills
that get passed that won't serve its
overarching purpose or has no Sunset
clause in it where we would actually
have to be forced to reevaluate it and
so I could go on and on and on look I I
this is my first full year in January
that I've been in Congress but I can
tell you that it was a lot more of a
broken institution than I even
understood when I was running for
Congress and I think that we have taken
this entire time many of us who are in
there who are true constitutionalist to
try and bring back what con our
Constitution and what our actual
Congress is supposed to be doing and and
and an old saying that I've heard
recently which I love which is that you
know change in the beginning it's very
hard in the middle it's very messy but
in the end is beautiful and we have to
understand that we're in that process I
want to jump to a very uh weird story
that I think it's important this from
The Economist one in five Young
Americans think the Holocaust is a myth
our new poll makes alarming reading so
they released this poll and you can see
18 to 29 year olds 20% believe the
Holocaust is a myth 30 to 44 it's just a
little bit less than 10 45 to 46
floating around one 65 plus almost zero
the Holocaust has been exaggerated same
stats basically slightly more 18 to 29
year olds just over 21 maybe around 22
or 23% and then about the same numbers
for the other demogra Graphics I find
this fascinating um in light of what we
just saw with the universities so this
all this all makes sense and I love by
the way that Elise stonic absolutely
just
eviscerated so this is this is a tweet
from her she says I was proud to co-lead
the 20120 bipartisan never again
Education Act to provide K through2
Federal grant funding for Holocaust
Education and have been co-leading the
bipartisan reauthorization this year but
these numbers from The Economist are
absolutely appalling chilling and
unacceptable I'm not here to tell you
what your opinions should be on any of
this stuff but I will but my point is
this the universities ban pronouns right
if they they ban wrong misgendering they
say fat phobia creates an unsafe
environment if you state facts that are
offensive to the individuals they will
come after you this is what we saw uh um
the Free Press as bar we's organization
put out this video and then they
defended and said if you call for the
genocide of Jews well now we got to talk
about the Constitution right you can see
where their views align and you can
understand then why you're also you're
seeing these two things play a role why
are young people so likely to believe
the Holocaust is either a myth or
exaggerated because these professors
right why are these professors willing
to defend under the guise of
constitutionalism the uh the right of
students to organize protests calling
for the uh the genocide of Jewish people
uh because they hold these views
themselves they will ban speech that
offends their power and then run and cry
and hide behind the Constitution to
defend the speech they like
the bigger picture here is universities
social media are subverting the young
people in this country to make them
oppose the worldview of the United
States our own our own histories and
thus I mean this what you got to
understand about this this data right
here it doesn't change yeah but 18 to 29
year olds in 10 years will just be in
the 30 to 44 year bracket right and so
your 65y Olds drop off and the bracket
continues down so what we need is making
sure we win this culture War yes to
shift things back in the direction of
pro-america believing history things
like that well and again I I've been
arguing that one of our greatest threats
as well is that culture social and
religious Warfare that we're seeing here
at home and that really starts with the
indoctrination that's going on in our
schools I mean it's it's also as I was
speaking yesterday uh at one of the the
Gatherings I I explained the fact that
you know it's intentional that we've
been removing Civics from our schools
because we don't want the younger
generation to actually understand what
their civic Duties are how to hold
government accountable and so all of
this in my opinion is just this
indoctrinated theory of how they're
actually doing things to try and weaken
the American values and and essentially
American exceptionalism of what we
actually stand for as a nation who's
doing it I mean the these professors
these uh universities these large donors
the George Soros of the world I mean
this is all part of it I mean your huge
endowments in who those Act ual alumni
who are donating into that are actually
I mean they would rather focus in on the
things like ESG CRT and Dei and
meanwhile strip out one thing which is
God and so that's what we have to start
thinking about well said I I think that
some of these 18 to 29 year olds might
be trolling I don't know how many of
them were actually pulled but it sounds
like something an 18 to 20 ny- old might
do is troll the internet and be like
yeah I think it was fake but like okay
it is important to see World War II from
the German perspective for sure it is I
was taught purely Amer perspective
growing up it's nice to see both sides
but I think it's I don't I cannot
dispute that these people were massacred
that the the Jews were rounded up on
trains and sent to like concentration
camps and starved to death do you think
it speaks to Jen cynicism that they just
don't really believe in anything anymore
including history in any way it was
presented to them and the way Nick
pentes like just has fun with it he's
like yeah whatever he just says it
because he gets a troll out of people
it's like it's it's it's it's not just
that it's sorry Nick when when you have
uh the women's March the organizer of
the women's March you had tablet
magazine released a story where they're
espousing insane conspiracy theories
about Jewish people the there's there's
a meme a joke about to figure out which
political faction you are simply insert
whichever group you hate into the
following sentences and then it's like
blank are responsible for all the world
wars blank control of the corporations
blank dox and it's just like you can
choose the 1% white privilege Jewish
people the Chinese the Russians and then
you figure out octarians yeah it's
basically just who do you hate the most
and you found you know so it's happening
is you have in universities these
professors we've seen this MH that that
woman from upen doing the Kubrick stair
you know what that is it's where you
tilt your head down and look up and
smirk while she's being asked is it
against the rules to call for the
genocide of Jews she look she look she
does the KUB spare smiles and goes in
certain contexts it's like this is a
person these are universities that that
have said you better not use the wrong
pronoun or else well but it's
interesting that you as you pointed out
earlier and correctly so you're talking
about how it's you know we don't want
our students to feel you know shamed we
don't want our students to feel at risk
but what about all of the Jewish
students right now who are actually
saying I don't feel safe on my campus
anymore I don't feel safe on my
universities I have threats against me
and we now have people who are actually
not just being you know investigated but
have actually been uh arrested for
making threats towards other Jewish
students I mean what about their
protection what about their voice what
about their right and and and and I'll I
I'll stress I always give my my my free
speech position is students should be
allowed to protest as long as they're
not harassing someone so they're hiding
behind the constitution in a way that
Free Speech Advocates would agree with
my point is that but the rest working in
in One Direction and and that's the
issue that I have with universities they
want to say that it's okay for you to do
one thing but then if someone says
something that's against your political
view or you believe then it's not okay
which exposes the hypocrisy correct
that's the point I want to say right now
just to you know get across with uh uh
leftism is overlapping with Nazism to
the greatest degree of any political
ideology that exists not fascism Nazism
explicitly um fascism you can make an
argument about like what were they
actually speaking to as a political
ideology Nazism was like yes plus they
wanted to kill Jewish people so when you
add this into it and you've got
professors that are effectively it was
the late David Graber he hated this but
they called him the anarchist
Anthropologist he said that elements of
the left have adopted the fascistic uh
moral framework of there is no truth but
Power it's like I agree with you there
David and when you add into the fact
that they hate Jews and don't believe in
the Holocaust and want to defend the
right to call for their genocide I think
now it's Nazism one of the things that
set the Nazis aside as a fascist
organization was their ethnocentrism
they were obsessed with white supremacy
so like seeing people talk poorly about
a race in any way sets my alarm Bells
off and so which which political faction
in this country wants racial segregation
again that's what I'm concerned with if
any of them want any form of it it
becomes very very dangerous let's go
back in time California was trying to uh
amend their constitution to allow for
segregation based on race in public
Contracting and education I this was
back in like 2018 they lost I was
talking to a friend of mine who's a
liberal Lefty prominent Hollywood person
and uh you know they had posted a
comment in support of it I had posted a
comment saying like this is shockingly
offensive to someone who comes from a
mixed race background that you would
allow them to hold this against me so
she calls me and she's like what do you
mean that's not no we're we're trying
what they wanted was affirmative action
we want universities to be able to help
people who are underprivileged and I was
like how many what's what's the
population uh uh demographics of
California and it's like oh it's like 70
something perent white and I was like so
your argument is that white people are
privileged are racist inherently racist
use these the systems of power for their
benefit and now you're arguing arguing
that white people should be allowed the
majority should be allowed to
discriminate against anyone based on
race in in public Contracting education
and that fixes the problem it's such a
hypocrisy I mean the way they they
handle themselves it's it's publicly
hypocrisy but when you understand what
they want to do you understand it's not
hypocritical at all it's exactly what
they want they want racial segregation
they want ethnocentrism or
identitarianism is probably a better way
to put it I think centrism is probably a
fine way to put it too they want
race-based law and when you add in the
fact they hate Jews they're Nazis the
Nazis specifically were like Aryans
first you know they were obsessed with
propelling one spe One race species I
almost said race is such a silly term
anyway it's not even a scientific term
but but then like the not the Jews and
the gypsies were like got the brunt of
the hate but it was everybody if they
weren't Aryan like they were second
class or less and so it's either you're
going to say this race is the best or we
have to kneecap that race either one is
is leads to that totalitarian Nazism
crap and so I'm I'm All About equality
of opportunity man I understand some
people's ancestors didn't have a lot of
nutrition maybe because they were born
from slave camps like 1860s all these
slaves let out of the South happened to
have be from one area of the world with
a certain type of genetics and so their
a their kids don't have good education
because they didn't have good education
they didn't have good uh nutrition
because they didn't so maybe their
brains aren't aren't getting what the
nutrition they need to really have
brilliance that's real that we got to
address that too but it it's like in a
free Society where where it's kind of up
to you to make the best of it and like
you got to trust hopefully you have good
parents it's it's you can't like
legislate the solution you can't throw
money at it yeah I do I mean I think
that there needs to be change at home on
the family level right all of these
things we could say this is an issue
this is a problem but ultimately unless
you have strong families nothing else
matters and we see this replicated
throughout American society right we are
less engaged with Community
organizations we tend Church less
regularly we are Stripped Away of all
the things that used to give us strong
tenants of culture and again drive
people back to their families and that
that is ultimately something that needs
more than a legislative change it needs
a psychological change in the homes of
every American well and again you know
think of someone who you know for
example if you look at my background you
know my mom and dad both had drug and
substance abuse issues and were in and
out of prison pretty much my entire life
my dad did almost 30 years in prison my
mom did almost 7 and a half years in
prison and I kind of bounced house to
house until I was finally adopted and
taken in by my grandparents who kind of
and again just a regular blue color
family you know my grandfather's a
welder my grandmother was a stay-at home
mom who would do hair on the weekends
you know she had taken her class through
cosmetology school so she'd do hair on
the weekends after church and things
like this but you know your
socioeconomic status doesn't Define who
you are I mean that's the whole point of
the greatness of America if you will and
I think that's one of the things we're
trying to water down and dilute and I
think a lot of people also have this
issue of self-victimization
where they just basically say well I
can't do this because of my upbringing
well you know I wasn't born into money I
me we we were thriving right above the
poverty line I mean I can remember when
my grandfather had a quadruple bypass
you know and he couldn't work any longer
and he was disqualified even though he'd
had five heart attacks from receiving
any type of disability benefits I mean
we lived for an entire year on around
$6,800 you know I mean there was a lot
of rice tomato gravy cornbread and you
know which now I absolutely crave when I
go back home you know but the whole
point is is that you know there's this
self-victimization that also is going on
in our country that we have to break and
understand that you know we are a nation
that believes in equal opportunity not
equal outcome and that's the difference
in my opinion between equity and
equality and the difference between what
the left and the right is trying to
bring to the table that's why I asked
earlier about gen Z being so cynical
right I mean gen Z especially teenage
girls report high levels of hopelessness
they there is a change in this
generation that I think is really
profound the fact that they just do not
believe in anything anymore and they are
expecting the worst always I think they
there is a culture especially among
progressives that believe they are
victims and that the system should
change for them but generally on either
side of the aisle or on either side of
the issue there is just sort of this
Sadness the I don't know if it was Ian
or if it was Tim who had made this
statement though but how much of that is
also just trolling you know with the
ears you know so I don't know it's well
the I'm referencing a study that the
federal government put out with a
teenage girls report high levels of
hopelessness and depression so it's it's
more than just one randomly trolling one
poll it's a it's it's definitely
different and I think that's why you
need more people like you out there
saying this is how I grew up and this is
what I did because I think there is just
this same thing like Byron Donald's I
mean Byron Donalds was raised by a
single mother in you know New York and
and they didn't have the best of things
well and all of these kids are online
where the algorithm feeds them more
victim hood or more depression right as
soon as you start reading sad stories
it'll feed you more sad stories to I'm
not going to allow there to be a glass
ceiling I'm going to go ahead and break
through that and I'm going to continue
to go ahead and Define myself by what
I'm willing to do you know creating a
worth work ethic understanding you know
what we need to be doing to try and
Achieve but also you know I used to
people would say you know well when my
grand when my father got out of prison
you know years years later I think I was
26 at the time and uh he was making an
apology and he had said you know I'm
sorry I couldn't have raised you to show
you like what it was or what the right
thing was to be a father things like
that and I said no you did and he said
well how is that and I said by doing
opposite you showed me exactly what I
don't want to be when I grew up you
showed me exactly what I want to do
opposite when I have kids and so again
we can break that cycle we don't have to
continue to try and self victimize we
can actually go ahead and say you know
what I'm not going to continue to
perpetuate this I'm not going to
continue to live this way and self
victimized I'm going to go ahead and
succeed because I'm going to build a
legacy for my kid and future generations
and I think that when you carry that
over you know whether it was my time in
uniform whether it was serving in the
government whether it was building
businesses and being a job Creator or
whether it's being a father which is the
greatest role in the world I think that
it's something that we always have the
ability to do what we want that's what's
great about America did you go through a
phase when you were young where it felt
hopeless and you were like how life was
so like dealt you a raw deal I mean look
there's that phase when you're like this
young 10-year-old I can remember one of
the one of the things that was difficult
for me I and it was kind of a a tough
story is like when I was 10 years old I
used to have this little uh suitcase and
I remember it was this baby blue
suitcase which had a little boy with
kind of a napsack and a dog and it said
going to Grandma's and it was you know
cuz I was raised by my grandparents and
I'd heard that my mom was going to come
pick me up and I hadn't seen her for a
while and uh as I get in the car with my
mom I can remember like we were driving
and all a sudden she like didn't want to
alarm me but she was kind of like first
time I understood oh by the way you know
I'm remarried and have another child you
know a daughter and so you get to this
well wait a second you know here I am 10
years old it's like well why couldn't
you have raised me if you can Al if you
can raise this other child and so yeah
you get these areas and these HS but you
also realize as you mature and you grow
up that all of the things that happen
make you who you are the good the bad
whatever happened in the middle I mean
that that transitory time when you're
coming from your adolescence and you're
going through puber you're going into
manhood and you're understanding what
that is but also I had I was very
blessed I had great role models you know
my grandfather is the greatest man I've
ever met you know if I could ever be
half of what my grandfather is I'd be
the greatest man and so you know he
understood work ethic and and he worked
as hard he understood the old way of
living he understood you know we ate at
the dinner table until I was 15 years
old you know and then when he was at
work working extra shifts U um you know
it was one of those ordeals where my
grandmother and I would like sneak off
into the living room to watch TV with
our TV trades you know I mean but but
that was the way old America was that
was the way you know and and no matter
how advanced we become no matter how
much things change and we evolve there's
certain parts of our American values and
what makes us Americans that we need to
hold on and we need to protect we need
to preserve for future generations and
so that's really you know part of uh in
addition to trying and get us back to
that America for constitutionality of
why Iran I think this show is kind of
like it's like being present with
someone is kind of a big that's sitting
at the dinner table with your family
because I'd be like why can't I just go
watch TV or play video games while I'm
eating and they' be like no you have to
sit at the table they never really said
why strong family is a strong Community
is a strong city is a strong county is a
strong state is a strong Nation you know
that's why they're trying to continue
with the with the radical left to attack
family to attack the role of father and
mother to you know basically trying to
deteriorate the importance and
significance of God it goes back to what
we said earlier in the where we said you
know we're really in Tim talked about
the culture aspect but the culture
social and religious Warfare that we're
challenging right now I mean we're we're
past the phase at this stage where it's
not about left vers right Dem vers
Republican conservative socialism it's
really America vers anti-america good
vers evil and so we have to just
acknowledge the fact that that's where
we're at in this nation and where we're
at in this world do you think people can
understand the difference do you think
can they can identify the difference I I
think you can absolutely discern between
the two I sometimes think that there
like are evil factions that present them
themselves good and there are people who
are tricked by it they can't tell the
difference and I think probably if you
good moral compass if you have good
character if you if you're developed you
can but people who are confused or
cynical or misled are more likely to be
misled do you guys think that Trump is
the Antichrist Tim did some research
this morning about it I'm kind of tongue
and- cheek because I all right there it
it was funny though uh yeah in the
culture War podcast we talked with a
couple guys about whether or not Trump
or Elon could be the Antichrist and uh
glad we have Detectives on the case yeah
so the funny thing is in Jewish gatria
Donald Trump is 424 and Messiah son of
David is also 424 so people are like oh
you know that that proves it or
something and like do you believe in
like biblical uh prophecy and stuff like
that or or what's your relationship with
God well I mean I I I grew up as a kid
who actually shared between half of my
family that was Catholic and half of my
family that you know was kind of Baptist
and and Pentecostal and and you know
just kind of the mix but um you know I
I'll tell you something we have to
understand that our entire Constitution
as it sits was based upon and founded on
our Christian judeo beliefs the idea was
to create it to where our inalienable
rights couldn't be infringed upon or
denied you know it was to understand the
jurisdiction between God to man and you
know the way government tries to run on
a specially and a dictator authoritarian
rule is they try and make it to where
it's almost as if you know the rule of
God or the inalienable rights of God is
afforded to the government to legislate
over then go to man I mean it's it's
it's a complete Ridiculousness in where
we've gotten so um you know we're a
nation founded upon our beliefs and so I
think that's what actually founds you
know certainly grounds me it's what
makes me who I am um and so you know for
me I I have a very strong belief and a
very strong uh faith in God yeah the
Constitution says that go God gives us
our inali rights from God so but I grew
up as an agnostic and that was fine the
country is like so liberal that it's
like you can believe whatever you want
as long as you pluralism exists I mean
that's one of the things we protect is
everyone's right to freedom to to to
belief to to religion to uh to thought
to speech I mean look these are all the
things regardless of what we don't have
to all agree upon the same thing in
order to still follow our Constitution
and be good Americans I think it does
affect how people view why we have the
rights we have though if you're like a
true atheist who doesn't believe in God
you are basically arguing that our
rights are a social contract that we
have agreed upon it doesn't come from
anything higher it's just the things
that we believe and collectively decided
that we going to maintain but we should
also understand as As Americans that we
also have a social contract to our
constitution we have a constitutional
Duty a civic duty to uphold and protect
this nation and protect the things and
preserve the things that we have for
future Generations that's where
economics come in because I think
money's messing it up like my love for
God is is Paramount but then I'm like
who cares about the just who cares about
getting rich it doesn't matter if your
name's on that bill like let's give
Grace do the right thing but then it's
like no I actually need to get that
guy's money because we are Liv in a
finite money Society where you got to
take it from someone else or print it
and devalue his his money that's a
Corruption of power that's a Corruption
of money the greed I mean that that's
something that's always existed that's
just yeah I mean look this is the reason
why I'm so concerned right now and
you've heard me just kind of a nauseum
about economic growth and where we need
to be at and how to sustain and
stabilize ourselves but you know we have
rulers right now in this regime this
Biden regime which is corrupted by the
money that they've received by whether
it's the the barisma money whether it's
the money out of Romania the the China
money the Moscow mayor you name it but
the point is is that there's a pay for
play and power here and and that needs
to have accountability and prevention
it's it it really just comes down to
short-term satisfaction long-term
satisfaction and it it it it appears to
be the tendency for the right is like
the heess first utilitarian purpos well
I mean look people who have kids are
thinking about the future people who
don't have kids want now the people who
want now are typical uh uh they want
their dopamine centers hit so they don't
care about anything give me the money
now pay off my debt why can't Biden just
pay off my debt who cares and then
everybody else who's got a problem with
that is thinking like what happens later
you sustainable resources that's what
it's really about having sustainable
access to electricity well but again
though if we had great quality of life
if we had a strong economy if we had
lower cost of living if everyone was
able not just to try and survive but to
thrive and they could do that on the
backs of where they are still working
they are still actually out there but
you know they're not trying to work in
the way that they have to right now
because of the 40-year high inflation
again this is where government can play
a role just into improving the quality
of life by trying to get cost of fuel
down by trying to get cost of living
Bound by trying to strengthen the dollar
through great economic growth strategies
by trying to stop us from this
interventionist ideology that we think
that we have to be the world's police I
mean there's there's so much that we can
do
that would actually help to quell some
of the kind of civil unrest that we see
or some of the cynicism by just trying
to improve the quality of life and
that's something the role of government
can actually do if you can reduce the
cost of electricity by hund by 100
basically by by to 100th of whatever it
costs now so like you start just pumping
out hydrogen at profit we have a hybrid
system it costs pennies instead of
dollars that would mean that the
national debt effectively even though it
would say 33 trillion it would actually
be only 300 billion like we would
legitimately by magnitudes reduce the
the defic the value of the deficit so
it's really about the value of the
number not the number itself well but
when we're talking about cynicism I'm
I'm I'm more just focused on the idea
that giving people the opportunity to
continue to try and you know go for
whatever it is that they want to go for
in this country without you know being
prohibited from it and just improving
the quality of life for every individual
I think is in itself achievable but you
know we're we're so divided and there's
so much partisan ship and there this
continuation of going after one another
as opposed to saying okay we have an
issue let's find a solution that works
for the majority of the people here and
it's not just free handouts it's not
this social welfare program that's being
weaponized it's actually government
getting in control of cost and ensuring
that we have a strong economy and that's
one of the things going back to the
Donald Trump comment I mean look we had
a great economy under Donald Trump we
had great foreign policy under Donald
Trump we were holding adversaries
accountable we were securing our borders
we were actually getting to that point
of prosperity we had full strategic
petroleum reserves we had you know you
go back we had the abam Accords we had
the idea that we were starting to
withdraw ourselves from these wars that
we never in my opinion should have ever
been involved in like Afghanistan or
Iraq or especially Syria or you know
myself and Matt Gates and many others
had voted for the repeal of aumf which
in my the the authorization of use of
military force in my opinion is an
abdication of our constitutional duties
under Article 1 Section 8 Clause 11 or
even the 73 wowers act but my mik guess
my point is is that you didn't see you
know the way it is now under President
Trump and that's why again I go back to
my original statement that we need a
president who is a proven leader who
understands economic growth because he's
a business guy who understands foreign
policy and he's proven that and who
doesn't have a reelection looming over
their head so they can make the
necessary and bold course corrections to
get our nation back on track to where we
can actually start to be prosperous
we're going to go to Super Chat so if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and head over to the best song ever.com
to pre-order together again which is our
modern version of the fake song It's a
real song the real classic the real
classic that was uh charted for 87 weeks
did you know that Ian 87 weeks that's
right 1967 1968 written by uh Jeremy
boring performed by and I think I don't
know if I don't know who gets the
writing credit so I'll be careful on
that one CU I know it was Jeremy but may
have been Michael and maybe not I don't
know Michael you can yell at me later
but it's Smokey Mike in the god king you
guys should definitely check out their
song which actually is really good and
Jeremy told us the story about why he
decided to make this song the long story
short of it is the music industry is one
of the institutions that's been
corrupted and so uh Jeremy and the daily
wire crew and him and Michael nolles
Smoky Mike and the god king is the is
their group decided to give a big middle
finger I thought it would be awesome if
we continued and took that and turned it
into another big middle finger so we are
basically making I guess you can just
call it a parody of modern pop music and
is a tribute you guys are making a
heartfelt tribute to Smoky Mike in the
god Kings absolutely it's the I think
it's the best song Carter's ever done
since he's been working and uh so good
produced by Carter Banks written by uh
Jeremy boring a smoky Mike and the god
king so I can I have no problem saying
it's the greatest song ever written cuz
I had nothing to do with it so I'm being
well you're you actually did spectacular
work as well you're one of the artists
songs but I am being humble when I say
it's the best song ever because someone
else wrote it you know we're just do has
nothing to do with the fact that you're
a part of it right well I didn't write
the original song so I I this song was
not written by me we just did a modern
cover version of it so no writing
credits here it's a tribute it's a
tribute they're showing respect Classic
this the hit 87 weeks on the chart as
they should in the in the in the event
we sell 500,000 of these for some reason
then you know daily wire can slap a gold
record on their wall and so can we nice
I don't that's not going to happen but
basically know this song is really
really good it is really good pop yeah
it's tough to to qualify a song without
having heard it without someone hearing
it so when you hear it you'll know yeah
it'll be uh it's going live next Friday
but pre-orders are up now meaning if you
go to the best song ever.com pre-order
on iTunes or Amazon that sale go sell uh
that sale goes towards our total count
for the following weeks or basically
given an extra week advantage to try and
knock some of these other contenders off
billboard what's the website the best
song ever.com okay I was writing that
article we did this that's the hilar
that's very funny yeah is the best song
ever to be fair the best song ever.com a
tribute to the best song ever written by
by Smoky Mike and the god king don't
look at me I'm not taking any
crits to the I am actually complimenting
them when I say it's the best song ever
you see or you say yours is the best
song ever wow it works in both
directions nope I did not write it and
Carter produced it so it's either praise
to Carter Banks or to Jeremy boring and
Michael nlls the best song ever.com
but the video is basically us making fun
of the weekend that be funny the next
time you release a song you can use the
same website and release it through the
best song ever.com
they're all the best song ever maybe I
don't know leave this one there all
right we'll grab some more uh we'll grab
some super chats Clint Torres says howdy
people howdy Clint you have the first
Super Chat congratulations Josh Burke
says on the Venezuelan thing from last
night something similar is happening
with ethiop Ethiopia and Eritrea MH oh
boy World War II you got Middle East you
got Eastern Europe you got a budding uh
uh wow East Africa end bcom and where uh
Indo Pacific command so oh yeah China
come on wow we're getting ready for it
huh all right what do we have we'll grab
some more Super chats I'm not your buddy
guy says is everyone okay in reference
to the first story uh I actually was
messaging Hunter uh they're okay only
the perpetrator is lost their life his
girlfriend was hurt but it's not too bad
and and uh it's non-life-threatening
injury that's what the police said yeah
there's photos of it they posted photos
of it and uh this a crazy story I mean
one of the things that hit me struck me
is the use of air tags the guy was
secretly putting air tags somewhere I
guess on their car or something I've
actually heard this fairly frequently of
girls who have like soccer boyfriends
that they'll like you know bug their
home or they'll like put air tags in
their vehicles or in something that they
their purse if they carry around every
day uh it's very scary and sad it's part
of the problem with technology and
domestic violence I guess according to
the text the purpose was to locate
Hunter's uh his home to figure out where
he lived and I guess that's what and
where she was going and when she so yeah
this is crazy cuz one day uh we and a
bunch of like it's you know Friday
nights afterwards we take a bunch of
people and we all go hang out at the
casino for a couple hours or whatever
one day when we came back my iPhone gave
me a warning saying you're being tracked
by an air tag that is not registered and
the scary thing is you go to the casino
you park your car someone slaps an air
tag on your car watches you the whole
time or like have a buddy in the parking
lot and then they'll basically Mark your
car if it's a nice car then they know
they follow you home then in the middle
of the night something bad happens and
so it turns out it was just someone else
who had an air tag which uh but it was
it was it was freaky nonetheless my
phone vibrates and it's like you have
been tracked by an air tag and it shows
the location of the casino to my house
so the crazy thing is it didn't show my
house to my house which would have been
fine i' like oh okay someone here has
one and so it was uh I don't want to
explain what we did security wise but
security things occurred and then we
cleared it and we were like wow you said
it was an iPhone that warned you my
iPhone sent me a warning you're being
tracked by airag I don't have an iPhone
and that's like is that a national
security threat that Apple can make
little tracking mechanisms or is that
just the inevitability Tey Tim or like
anyone who thinks they might have a
stalker right if your iPhone says hey
it's registering something that
shouldn't be there the question is like
can Android start picking up on that as
well that would be cool so uh we'll grab
some more superat quisby J says hey Ian
have you seen the graphine battery
durability tests on YouTube negative but
I will this guy he claims to be a
graphine he's the Lord I'm just the
messenger he has been hydrogen fuel
selling the entire show he's got some
hydogen right there the byproduct
graphine getting paid by big hydrogen I
mean I think he's B and paid for by for
every kilogram of hydrogen you make you
get $4.50 of graphine as a byproduct so
you you flash the plastic and then you
get the gas you get the fuel the gas
whatever hydrogen gas and then you get
the but yeah clearly sound like someone
who get paid by this stuff you pour into
like concrete to make it three times
more durable you can put it in uh car
doors to make them stronger lighter it's
200 times stronger than steel by by by
weight uh and this is just in the bulk
version of it stuff yeah man this is the
21st century Building Material right
here all right Andrew 843 says the major
Richard star act would give service
members who are medically retired due to
combat injuries their retirement pay mhm
very cool talked about that uh a bit
last night that's correct Max re says
hey Tim do you think you could briefly
explain section 230 I see people on the
left say that conservatives are dumb for
thinking that companies like Twitter are
getting protection as a platform and
publisher thoughts platform versus
publisher is completely mean meaningless
has nothing to do with Section 230
section 230 gives broad immunities to uh
websites that's it there's a lot of
people who are like you know uh Twitter
by editorializing has become a publisher
but that literally has nothing to do
with Section 230 section 230 should
stand but section 230 should be enforced
properly in that idea
the idea being if uh uh you're
protected in so so the argument for
platform versus publisher is this we
want it to be that if you are a neutral
Arbiter on the pl that allows people to
speak and you don't intervene in
political opinions then you have
protections from liability however once
you begin removing content you don't
like you lose liability protections the
problem with that is there are uh
there's certain content that uh uh most
people agree should be removed or would
need to be removed so then these
platforms need to intervene and that is
like basic moderation violence privacy
violations I think the easiest one is
doxing everybody agrees you shouldn't
post uh identifying information of
someone else but it's not illegal to do
so you can go in public and hold up
someone's private information and it
just it's annoying so in this regard the
argument is if Twitter is going so
section 230 says you can remove things
that are obscene uh uh lwd lascivious
criminal Etc without losing your
protection what we want is for the law
to say yes you can get rid of things
that are criminal activities or are
obscene but opinions ah there's the
problem the argument these platforms
make is hate speech is an obscenity
swearing is an obscenity therefore
either it's it's one or nothing so
people on the right are basically saying
look we get it you want to remove videos
of like child abuse but some guy saying
that he you know he doesn't he say hasht
learn to code that shouldn't be removed
these companies are arguing that
basically child abuse and hashlearn to
code are the same thing and it's an
opinion so who gets to decide what
speech is to be removed and which isn't
so it's it's it's a mess it's it's
difficult I mean a guy saying something
like child abuses great you know like
that kind of statement technically is
completely legal and in my opinion
acceptable because it's legal even
though it's horrible so if if if someone
says hey I don't want to be held liable
for the speech of the people the
platform we say okay you're immune from
the speech on on the platform they say
okay but we got a bunch of child abuse
stuff can we remove that without losing
our Li our liability protection section
230 says yes you can they say oh okay
Ian you're removed too because you said
something offensive I know it's crazy
that's not good enough we need a better
system right so that this is this is a
big challenge uh that's why it's people
have gone back and forth with just
repealing section 230 outright which
wouldn't work because then basically you
could just Sue YouTube for what someone
else posted on YouTube that doesn't
solve the problem you can let the
communities kind of kind of take control
of moderation that's what we're
experimenting with at mines where you
have a jury if someone reports something
that goes to a jury of users on the site
they can vote if it's violating it or
not but then who writes the terms of
service I mean mines terms of service is
US law if it's legal in the United
States it's legal on mines then there's
things like spam which is doesn't
correlate to what that mean so you take
spam US law is not always applicable to
the challenges of the internet let's
let's read this here from Craig Charlton
he says everything cheesecake in
Martinsburg wants to connect they
offered a private tasting for the
timcast crew check it out okay I've
heard everything cheesecake is amazing
I've heard like yeah and they open they
moved location somewhat recently I don't
I don't remember exactly where but there
are family own business they've been
around forever I stalk all the
Martinsburg businesses into it I like
look up everything everything cheesecake
oh I found it oh okay right on yeah our
plan for uh oh okay so great that's on
Route 11 Chistmas party Route 11 becomes
Queen Street so uh our plan for
Martinsburg is we want to bring a whole
bunch of
parallel economy businesses to physical
locations and make an anti-time Square
while the the number one the the first
rule what was that uh uh you might know
this Ian the three rules for robots what
was it called geez I don't know anyway
the first rule is businesses that exist
can't be displaced so if anything that
we're doing puts pressure on on those
businesses we have to contribute to make
sure that they don't get displaced by us
trying to revitalize three laws of
robotics yeah Asimov laws robotics
as's laws of building bus in martinburg
is we cannot cause problems for the
existing businesses that are
there which would protect a lot of our
mom and pop shops which is Whata we want
because we're we're talking about we're
we're setting up our coffee shop skate
shop private club which is currently
underway the private club's probably
going to be sooner and the only reason
we haven't done it is because we thought
the coffee shop was going to be sooner
but it's been a disaster it's been it's
just been taking so long to get
everything done and it's mostly because
contractors show up present plans sign
papers announce their scheduled start
date and then vanish and are gone should
we do something like um create a union
of localized businesses for the area
because if someone goes in there and
they set up a shop and then they they
like like a like uh like Business Bureau
lots of towns have like I don't I don't
I don't like that idea but like if
someone comes might already exist if
someone goes in and then they undercut
the other businesses they're like yeah
we're not going to displace anyone they
go and displace everyone like you have
no recourse unless it's contractually
part of the community or something yeah
I think if you did that you would have
the ey like the the goal of making an
anti-time square is that it's going to
be attached to the parallel economy any
business that came in and tried to
destroy a business inside it would be
trying to destroy the whole project so I
I I don't think anyone would try and do
that because you would be
destroyed like that just you're your
business would fail and you'd lose all
your money in your Starbucks is like
it's going to bring a100 million into
the community you guys and then they're
faced with a massive boyot constant
social media pressure and they're why
would they do that on
purpose they would
um yeah Al They D but yeah everything
cheesecake we'll have to check that one
out trust anybody when it comes to money
Oscar Olu says damn it please stop
saying guns can be 3D printed the 3D
printed guns that can fire without metal
are complete trash stop perpetuating
that lie no good sir you are wrong uh
not only are uh uh would I disagree I
guess I guess 3D printed guns that can
be printed without metal are complete
trash you are misconstruing the argument
about 3D printing guns you can take a a
CNC machine at home and cut a lower
receiver out of metal very easily and uh
watch infringed on
timcast.net
block can be sent to your home and then
if you choose I'm not advocating this
you can put it into an at home CNC
machine we actually have two of them I
think and it will cut a lower receiver
right there so yes 3D printing at it can
be done I guess you can argue that's not
3D printing the fact is the home
manufacturer of weapons of Guns is it's
it's here and I got to tell you man it's
so easy that the average person who
wants to buy you know your standard
AR-15 they could easily just buy a 3D
printer and at home CNC machine for half
the cost and then get sent a 0% receiver
it's it's this stuff's easy so when I
say 3D printed guns I'm not literally
saying only plastic I'm saying the atome
manufacturer of all parts of a gun can
be easily done and you can make a full
metal gun with that at home C CNC
machine so Hey look it's here cats out
of the
bag what do we have we'll grab some more
Super
chats what is this Allan shower says Tim
massive culture War opportunity poo V
Hannah B vises Taylor Swift
why Poo's anti Taylor Swift and I don't
know who Hannah B is my name is Hannah
Claire but uh Jack bobic is walking to a
trap why he's walking into a trap he's
he he posted that tweet criticizing
Taylor Swift yeah that's a s up I
thought her interview was super boring
for time I did not think it was that
interesting at all she's just rehashing
old stuff you guys are letting her live
in your head in a way she shouldn't no
and I say that someone who went to her
concert and this is the S up Taylor
Swift a couple years ago criticized
George Soros MH why would any
conservative in their right mind be like
quick now we have to attack Taylor Swift
like are you nuts she just she just
accused the Soros family of buying her
music out from under her you should be
like we also don't like the Soros family
maybe we can work together yeah instead
all these conservatives are posting
accusing her of working with George
Soros I got to tell you if you want to
make enemies with the most famous
celebrity in the world that's how you do
it imagine you get knifed in the back by
a guy and then you get pissed off go
online and say this dude just knifed me
in the back and then everyone comments
saying yeah but you're secretly working
with him so we don't we don't like you
screw you you'd be like are you kidding
me where's the support man so I'm like
your best case scenario with Taylor
Swift ignore Taylor Swift might come out
in 2024 endorse a Democrat so be it
every other celebrity will too don't
make enemies your best bet is to be like
that's that's what I'm saying look if
you see a Taylor Swift person you know
like wearing a shirt or whatever you got
instant Rapport right now and she might
might be going to vote Democrat and you
got to yell at her or him whatever maybe
it's a guy you just be like you know I
got something in common with Taylor
Swift George Soros the stuff that he
funds not only did he steal from Taylor
Swift that's got to piss you off but
he's funding these da so I'm right there
with her she she was right to call him
out now you're friends with theft Swifty
to to the other side I love it I can't
stand that like my my opinion on this is
the only appropriate political
commentator uh stance on Taylor Swift is
oh I don't know I guess mhm
now okay fine maybe maybe your political
commentary overlaps in the music
industry and so you're like I really
don't like pop music that's totally fine
but it makes no sense that people who
aren't attached to this industry are
like oh Taylor Swift someone came to me
like what do you think about Taylor
Swift I'd be like oh love song was good
she got some pop songs I I I mean what
you're saying which is which is really
kind of what everyone should be looking
at is that you're trying to say well hey
look I'm I'm I'm looking for
commonalities not what separates us I
mean that was that was the whole point
point of like what I took from the
analogy which is like oh you were to
tell your oh yeah we don't like what
Soros did either like you're trying to
find that commonality instead of
continuing to try and SE in the why why
make enemies yeah you could we we got a
big opportunity right here there's that
viral video going around where Taylor is
talking they claim it's Taylor opposing
Trump and I'm like the first and
foremost I don't care about Taylor Swift
it just annoys me that you Sun read
sunsu man you don't go to war with
someone you can't win a war against you
there is no no reality in which any
Trump supporter wins a culture war with
Taylor Swift the only thing you can do
is isolate her fan base so your best bet
is to ignore at the very least or you
can be like man did you see how the
Soros has ripped off Taylor that's so
messed up yeah she's great that's it she
she makes good pop music I don't know
billionaire Banker bought her music so
uh scooter braa and uh Alex Soros and
the Soros family financed the purchase
of her master recordings so that
basically gave them the rights to all
the everything that was distributed
afterwards I guess what happened was
they spent $330 million on it she
couldn't afford to do it because she
didn't think the return was going to be
there I mean it's a she she's worth 1.1
billion but she doesn't she wasn't then
though but even even now she doesn't
have 330 billion 30 million in cash so
she couldn't buy her own music tweeted
saying like these people ripped me off
fine hope it's worth it for you and now
because she owns the composition rights
she's re-recording it all oh cool at
Kelly Clarkson suggestion it's brilliant
W that's awesome I'm just like she put
out there's a video that everyone's
sharing because attacking her and in it
she says if if uh if he doesn't win at
least I
tried right dude mean she's supporting
Donald Trump we should record something
with Taylor for her if she's
re-recording her stuff come no it's like
it's like bullet point song great
worldom Ian Ian will be like we should
get Brad Pit on the show like well I'm
not like tomorrow but I'm saying put it
on the bullet board like got a sticky
note over there H by jly if Hassan wants
to come on I'm open and there was one
about working out and you went on your
Fitness this year he I think he was the
one that forced me to write that down or
he wrote it hey I I'm just holding you
your word brother I put things on bullet
boards in my mind and like say yes to it
vision boards all right let's read some
more Super chats the text vet says as a
combat vet I would never recommend
anyone join until things are squared
away combat cannot be effective until
all the wokeness goes away and unit
cohesion and Trust can be made priority
again what do you think about this well
I mean he's right I mean at the end of
the day what we have to understand is
that we have to have cohesiveness we
have to have that Unity we have to have
that Brotherhood we have to be ready to
you know Walk Line to Line it's
interesting that this whole idea of
introducing and trying to make the
prioritization of Dei as the key has
actually so in more divisiveness into
our military when it should be about us
all going down range together and you
know looking to try and come home
together so um you know we are doing
that I I passed over 20 plus amendments
in the National Defense authorization
act that targets Dei and that actually
looks at the protection of our military
to try and get them back to what it
really was about which was back then
increase with ality Readiness and being
properly equipped not diversity equity
and
inclusion it's cool it's much needed I
think did the oh sorry to interrup oh I
was just going to say there's it's it's
sad to see sort of the way the military
has uh made fun of or sort of mistreated
regular Americans saying no you won't be
able to see the difference we'll just
push this agenda and then they started
to repeal it when they thought maybe
we're going to need to up the day every
one of our men and women in uniform who
I have a tremendous amount of respect
and who I will fight to the very end to
try and protect to make sure that they
have what they need they need to get
back to what it is to serve this country
not serve anyone's political agenda who
sits in the office yeah and that's
really what it's about we got a good one
wrath says get Angel Studios to make a
sound of Freedom like movie but based on
the events of Cory Mills testimony in
Afghanistan and Israel I thought the
same thing man that'd be cool
Afghanistan would be I think that's a
movie right there for sure would you
play yourself in the movie or would you
have someone else do it you no you got
to have someone play you you know
oh interesting I was going to say the
same thing I'm I'm I don't know I'm
going to try and probably recruit
Bradley Cooper he's good one he was
really good in American Sniper and uh a
couple other moves I think he's a good
actor but you know there there was a lot
that was in that that was uh very
interesting you know a lot of people
didn't know that right before we were
able to get miam and her family out uh
you know if you dial from an American
Film regardless of where you're at
internationally it'll automatically
register as plus one but with a lot of
your satellite phones it'll
automatically just take the first number
and take it over as it is an actual uh
country code and so one of the things
that we had to do since we were getting
no help whatsoever from the American
government and the state department was
working against us is that I had
remember you know memorized all the
bassport birth dates and had convinced
one of the Taliban commanders that was
that one of the checkpoints that I was
the husband and the father of these
three children and memorized their you
know address their date of birth you
know hospitals things like this had
proof of life and proof of understanding
and then a guy that was with us who you
know I'm I'm a fluent Arabic speaker um
but there's a guy who is a fluent Posh
chudari and tajic speaker um who was
with us who we had convinced that he was
just the interpreter and uh we played a
bit of Shell Games with the satellite
phones where we were calling with the
satellite phones because we had just
heard that Cabell had got the order to
shut down all the borders and that we
knew it would take a while for it to go
from kabell to Mazar Shar Mazar Shar out
to kandu kandu these little outposts and
so we know we had a little bit of time
but we called from multiple phones and
had convinced the commander that uh
Yousef one of the guys that was with us
was actually one of the negotiators in
Qatar and that this family was part of
that negotiation and that that would
break down if we didn't allow these
American family out and so um it was
interesting because when we went across
we had our full team originally and they
would only allow two of us to come over
and and then re take hold of a physical
custody of of the the children and the
actual mother and I can remember the
commander on the other side saying look
there's probably about a 50% chance that
they're going to shoot you when you get
over there and my friend didn't find it
as funny but I just said well those are
pretty good odds and uh apparently had a
lot more to live for um but you know it
was one of those things where uh when we
got them across the border and we'
actually gotten them into safety and and
we knew that there was no longer a great
risk of the Taliban R to try to take at
him I started getting all these messages
on my phone from that talibana Commander
swearing being like you tricked me I
just knew I should so it it literally it
literally was from the time that we had
gotten him physically on to the other
side he had already gotten finally that
relayed message that no one in or out
and uh so we just broke it by the Edge
of Time to to be able to get that family
yeah that's a movie right there dude
that was a good it was somebody call
Bradley Cooper and AEL Studios I mean
well yeah crazy yeah definitely Angel
Studios but someone's got to make the
film right so there's the story
someone's got to make the torch and pass
it on all right let's see we'll grab uh
we'll grab one more here Paul tascos big
old Super Chat appreciate it says SSR
cry anti-depressants ruined my life
began at 30 years old gained 100 lb
emotionally numb no hope I wasn't living
just existing dead inside took 12 months
to taper off severe withdrawal symptoms
anger crying for hours I'm 38 years old
now SSRI free for 9 months I'm healing
learning to love myself don't give up
God bless you good luck man that was
Andy that was Paul tascos Paul tascos
nice job dude keep the fight going right
on man all right everybody if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
head over to
timcast.net best song ever that's
lukowski's influence all over you best
uh well it was Carter's idea oh my gosh
music producer being like here we go
this is the URL I mean it's a smoky mic
and the god King Classic one we have to
honor them correctly but um when when we
so so Michael knows we've been working
on this for a year it's been a long time
and uh Michael was here and I don't I
don't know if he's get mad that I said
this but he was like Tim I just want a
gold record and I was like okay we got
to sell 500,000 of these but you know
maybe in like 10 years something happen
this is a really good song though this
is one that catches by Word of Mouth
maybe I don't know uh I like it it's
it's like a modern pop version uh we
like we're basically starzing modern pop
like the weekend the music video is
basically a spoof of the weekend and uh
the idea was to take daily wire uh jere
Jeremy borings spoof of happy together
and then turn it into a spoof of modern
music so that we could basically double
up and give a middle finger to the
industry and the the not not to say it's
it's the equivalent of I'm trying to
make a comparison but I mean we did see
what happened with the great song the
richm men north of Richmond I mean that
thing just absolutely exploded this song
is nothing like that don't set the bar
too high my point is that it doesn't
necessarily have to be some big label I
mean it could actually just be a group
of people who make a really good song
and it just catches fire to to Ian's
point to be fair like you guys have been
working on you launched a legitimate
trash house is a legitimate label you
guys are really committed to fighting
back against it was a year ago it was a
year ago that I called Jeremy boring I
was like Jeremy I have this idea and he
was like okay and then uh we started
working on it in communication with them
they cameo in the video and uh it's
going to be fun and funny see it yeah so
uh would appreciate your support the
best song ever.com and uh Corey do you
want to shout anything up uh no I just
want to go ahead and thank you guys for
having me back on the show and and look
you know I uh I represent I'm elected to
Florida's 7th District but I can tell
you if you believe in constitutionality
you believe in the freedom of this
Republic you believe in the ideas of
maintaining our anable rights and
getting back to what it was to being an
American then trust me I'm still your
representative regardless of where
you're living in this world are you on
Twitter on I am on Twitter Cory Mills FL
um and then I've got uh I think our
Instagram and Our Truth is is both the
same cool that's awesome well thanks for
coming in it's been a great show so much
I appreciate it um I'm Hannah clar brimo
I'm a I'm a writer for cnr.com that's
scanner news I'm really glad to be a
part of that team uh the Whalers have a
big game this weekend so go watch them
that's that's a complete lie uh if you
want to follow scanners work you can
still follow at Tim news on Twitter and
Instagram if you want to follow me
personally I'm on Instagram at han. and
I'm on or on X or whatever it's called
at HC brimlow guys thank you so much yes
thank you very much subscribe to me over
over the Internet atan Crossland and
follow watch my YouTube video today with
Drew Pinsky because it was awesome great
interview love the guy love you drew
dude Corey awesome awesome I love
talking economics thank you for bringing
the numbers going deep that was badass
looking forward to seeing you again man
absolutely Serge D pre yeah uh surge.com
another good week ready to uh enjoy my
weekend like you guys should too uh
argue with me on Twitter see you guys
later now we're going to be doing work
for the boonies HQ which is happening
this weekend we got some uh uh I guess
we got some pro skateboard coming out
it's going to be a lot of fun so we'll
be producing more content for you follow
at Boonies HQ everywhere thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
cheers
I